GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM MANY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE THANK
THEM FOR THEIR- FOR THEIR TIME
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
pMUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YES EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE IT
USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM ANY TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR A INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE WILL
BE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE IT WILL
BE PLACE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I ONE OUNCE NOW TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. X. CODE
NINE ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL BE HEARING ALL
THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE HAVE
SHARED ALL OF THE WITNESSES
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES
EXCUSE ME WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE-
TOPICS OF TODAY'S. AGENDA PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING- ON
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM AS WELL DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE FOR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WELCOME MEMBERS TO OUR VERY
FIRST INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
TODAY WE WILL BEGIN LOOKING AT
OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE THE EMISSIONS FROM
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
AS WELL AS OFF ROAD VEHICLES.
THESE VEHICLES PLAY A VERY
CRUCIAL ROLE AND I'VE HEARD FROM
MANY MEMBERS ON THEIR STANCE ON.
ON ON WHAT LIKE THEY'D LIKE TO
SEE BUT THE MID DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNTS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. AND OTHER TOXIC
POLLUTANTS SO WE MUST ACT NOW.
AND BECAUSE OF WHERE THESE
VEHICLES OPERATE THEY HAVE AN
ESPECIALLY LARGE IMPACT AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SO
TODAY WE WILL LOOK AT OUR
EFFORTS TO TRANSITION INTO MUCH
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES. WE'LL LOOK
AT BOTH THE VEHICLES AND THE
FUELING SUPPLY AND DISTRIBUTION
CHAIN. AND I HOPE YOU GET A
REALISTIC PICTURE OF WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT AND WHEN WE CAN EXPECT
IT. WILL BE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPORT ITS CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY TRANSITION. SO WE OWE
IT TO OUR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TO BE SURE WE'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY EFFICIENTLY. RESPONSIBLY
AND WITH EQUITY IN MIND. SO WITH
THAT LET'S BEGIN OUR HEARING.
WILL START WITH OUR CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD CHAIR LIANE
RANDOLPH. A TO RANDOLPH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND THROUGH
THE MAGIC AND SCREEN SHARING- I
WILL SHARE- A VERY BRIEF- POWER
POINT. THE. AS THE CHAIR NOTED
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHICH
INCLUDES THE EMISSIONS FROM.
SORRY HOMELAND I'M HIDING I
THINK OKAY. IT'S PETITIONS WHICH
INCLUDES EMISSIONS FROM BOTH
VEHICLES DIRECTLY AS WELL AS
FROM EXTRACTING REFINING AND
TRANSPORTING THE FUEL IS NEEDED
TO POWER THEM IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MORE THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
CONSTITUTES THE MAJORITY OF SMOG
CAUSING POLLUTANTS AND IS A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACT COMMUNITY HEALTH
SPECIFICALLY THESE EMISSIONS
CONTRIBUTE TO A WIDE RANGE OF
HEART AND LUNG ILLNESSES CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS INCREASED
CANCER RATES AND PREMATURE
DEATH. EVERY YEAR OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PREMATURE DEATHS AND
HUNDREDS OF ILLNESSES AND
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS FOR
RESPIRATORY AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE IN CALIFORNIA ARE LINKED
TO PM TWO POINT FIVE POLLUTION.
OF WHICH MORE THAN HALF IS
PRODUCED BY THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. RECENT RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT FINE
PARTICULATE POLLUTION IMPACTS
NOT ONLY THE HEART AND
RESPIRATORY SYSTEM BUT ALSO
BRAIN HEALTH AND ADVERSE BIRTH
OUTCOMES. ADDRESSING EMISSIONS
FROM THIS SECTOR WILL BE
PARAMOUNT IN ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
GOALS. WELL THE FOCUS OF THIS
HEARING IS ON THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES I WANT TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES. AS THEY PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SPACE AND OFFER
VALUABLE CONTEXT. IN CALIFORNIA
THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE SECTOR
CONTRIBUTES A SIZEABLE
PROPORTION OF CURRENT KNOCKS AND
GHG EMISSIONS LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES CONTRIBUTE ABOUT 28% OF
THE GHG EMISSIONS. REPRESENTING
THE LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF
COMEDY MISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ALSO ACCOUNTED FOR ABOUT 9%
OF TOTAL KNOCKS AND MISSION
STATEWIDE IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
RBC CAN TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
THESE VEHICLES BY CLEANING UP
CONVENTIONAL CARS AND
ACCELERATING THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. WITH
RESPECT TO CLEANER VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES CARB STAFF ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON THE ADVANCE
CLEAN CARS TO OUR WHAT WE CALL
EASY TO PROGRAM THAT WILL TAKE
US FOR MODEL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
SIX TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
TIGHTENING STANDARDS WHERE
NECESSARY AND PURSUING
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
WILL TRANSLATE TO REAL WORLD
EMISSION BENEFITS FROM INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES. ACC TWO IS
ONE AMONG SEVERAL PROGRAMS
ADDRESSING EMISSIONS FROM LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES OTHERSINCLUDE THE
CLEAN MILE STANDARD THE SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
A NUMBER OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
THAT REDUCE THE HIGHER UP FRONT
COST OF SAYS AND SUPPORT
ALTERNATIVES TO OWNING A
PERSONAL VEHICLE. AND WE MUST
REDUCE DEPENDENCE ON DRIVING
THROUGH MORE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER YOU LIVE IN THE
BAY AREA SEVEN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ALL
CALIFORNIANS NEED THEIR LEADERS
TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES TO REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED BECAUSE
THE HEALTH OF OUR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES DEPENDS ON IT. I
WILL NOW TURN TO MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND THE
ACTIONS CARPET IS TAKING TO
CLEAN UP THE FLEET. TRUCKS MAKE
UP ONLY 6% OF THE STATE'S
VEHICLE POPULATION BUT THEY
REPRESENT ALMOST A QUARTER OF
THE STATE'S TRANSPORTATION GHG
EMISSIONS. AND NEARLY HALF OF
THE KNOX EMISSIONS. ADDRESSING
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT FROM
TRACKS AND FREIGHT MOVEMENT IS
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR GOALS.
THIS IS MY CHOSEN ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED BY CAR TO ESTIMATE
POTENTIAL CANCER RISK FROM
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER
EMISSIONS. OR DTM AS NOTED IN
THE FIGURES. YOU'RE ON THE LEFT
SHOWS RELATIVE CANCER RISK
ACROSS THE STATE ON THE RIGHT WE
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITIES TO
SHOW THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
DIESEL PARTICULATE EMISSIONS CAN
HAVE IN AND AROUND THOSE
COMMUNITIES. HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT ASSOCIATED
WITH INDUSTRIAL PORT AND
WAREHOUSE ACTIVITIES ARE A
DOMINANT SOURCE FROM DIESEL
PARTICULATE EMISSIONS IN MANY
COMMUNITIES. WELL DIESEL
PARTICULATE EMISSIONS ARE
PROJECTED TO DECREASE BY 80%
FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
THIRTY AS A RESULT OF STATE AND
LOCAL REGULATIONS AND INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THERE IS STILL MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE TO REDUCE
EXISTING BURDENS AND RISKS IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF REDUCING
EMISSIONS FROM EXISTING TRACKS
AND CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS.
THE TRUCK AND BUS REGULATION
ADOPTED MORE THAN A DECADE AGO
WILL REACH FULL IMPLEMENTATION
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE ARE NEARLY ALL HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL TRUCKS WHEN THE TO HAVE
CLEANER TWENTY TEN OR NEWER
ENGINES. THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS REGULATION FOR AIR QUALITY
THROUGH THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE BY
SENATOR ABOUT. WHICH GAVE THE
WORLD SHEET THAT CARD COULD NOT
BY DISALLOWING NON COMPLIANT
VEHICLES FROM REGISTERING WITH
THE DMV. THIS SLIDE SHOWS
REGULATIONS CARDS HAVE CARP HAS
ADOPTED WELL WILL BE CONSIDERING
FOR FUTURE ADOPTION. THE ITEMS
CAPTURED ABOUT THE TIMELINE ARE
ZERO EMISSION REGULATION. ZERO
EMISSION AND ELECTRIC INCLUDE
BOTH HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
AS WELL AS BATTERY ELECTRIC. ARE
THERE REGULATIONS FIRST TARGETED
BUS BUSES AND AIRPORT SHUTTLES
AND HAVE SINCE EXPANDED TO
TRUCKS WITH OUR ADVANCE CLEAN
TRUCKS RULE. THAT RULE IS THE
FIRST IN THE WORLD REGULATION
THAT REQUIRES TRUCK
MANUFACTURERS TO TRANSITION FROM
DIESEL TRUCKS AND VANS TO
ELECTRIC ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
. THIS REGULATION WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY THE COMPLIMENTARY
ADVANCE CLEAN FLEETS WERE ALL
THAT WILL ENSURE. AN ENGINE
TRUCK SALES CONSISTENT WITH
GOVERNING NEWS AND ZERO
EMISSIONS THANK YOU TO ORDER.
ELIMINATING TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
THROUGH ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY
WILL REDUCE CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
TOXICS AND GHG EMISSIONS
SIMULTANEOUSLY. THIS HELPS US
NOT ONLY ACHIEVE OUR ERRANT
CLIMATE GOALS BUT IMPROVES
PUBLIC HEALTH ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE PRIORITY COMMUNITIES MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POLLUTION. IN ADDITION TO OUR
REGULATIONS WHICH ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY CARP ALSO FINDS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO FOSTER
INNOVATIVE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE SECTOR AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO ASSIST IN THE
EARLY YEARS OF TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENT AND MARKET
INTRODUCTION. COMPLEMENTARY TO
CARBS DURING MISSION EFFORTS IN
THIS SPACE WE HAVE ALSO PUT IN
PLACE MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES OPERATE AS
CLEANLY AS POSSIBLE. A FEW
EXAMPLES OF THESE PROGRAMS
INCLUDE THE HEAVY DUTY OMNIBUS
REGULATION. AND THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR AND BOARD
MEMBER CONNIE LEYVA. A FIRST OF
ITS KIND SMOG. WE MAY HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES TO RANDALL CAN
YOU HEAR US. TECHNOLOGIES IN OFF
ROAD APPLICATIONS. RELATED TO
FREIGHT MOVEMENT SPECIFICALLY WE
ARE PURSUING REGULATIONS FOR
TRANSPORTATION REFRIGERATION
UNITS AND CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT AT SEA PORTS AND RAIL
YARDS. OTHER EXAMPLES NOT SHOWN
ON THE SLIDE INCLUDE PLANS TO
PHASE IN ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY IN COMMERCIAL HARBOR
CRAFT LARGE SPARK IGNITION
EQUIPMENT AND EQUIPMENT WITH
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES. AN
EXAMPLE OF THE BENEFITS THAT
HEAVY DUTY EMISSION REDUCTIONS
MEASURES COMES IN THE LATEST
REPORT JUST RELEASED BY THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT. THIS REPORT
SHOWS THAT REGULATIONS ON HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES HAD SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT IN PARTICULAR
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. COURT
FINDS THAT DIESEL PARTICULATE
CONCENTRATIONS FROM HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES DECREASED BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE MOST SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTIONS
WERE IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED. IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AVERAGE DIESEL
PARTICULATE LEVELS DROPPED TO
LESS THAN 25% OF THEIR TWO
THOUSAND LEVELS BY TWENTY
NINETEEN. HOWEVER DESPITE THIS
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT THESE
COMMUNITIES STILL FACE
INEQUITABLE AIR POLLUTION
BURDENS COMPARED TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND GREATER ACTION
WILL BE NEEDED TO CLOSE THE GAP
. SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO OF ECO
REQUIRES THAT WE USE ONLY ZERO
EMISSION HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND IS
EXPECTED TO REDUCE DIESEL
PARTICULATE CONCENTRATIONS BY
58% COMPARED TO CURRENT
STANDARDS. THESE REDUCTIONS
COULD AVOID THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
PREMATURE DEATHS STEMMING FROM
DIESEL EXPOSURE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR WE COUNT FOR TWO THIRDS OF
THESE AVOIDED DEATHS. OUR FOCUS
MUST BE ON TRANSITIONING TO ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY AS QUICKLY
AND AS POSSIBLE AND AS WIDELY AS
POSSIBLE TO MAXIMIZE THE HEALTH
BENEFITS. THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
SETS CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO
COMPLETELY TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. HOWEVER LOW
CARBON ALTERNATIVE FUELS WILL
STILL PLAY A KEY ROLE IN MEETING
OUR GHG AND AIR QUALITY GOALS IN
THE NEAR TERM. AND THE ORDER
CALLS FOR CONTINUED FOCUS ON
DECARBONISING ALTERNATIVE FUELS
THAT DISPLACE FOSSIL FUELS IN
VEHICLES THAT STILL RELY ON
COMBUSTION. THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD OR LCS FAST IS THE
STATE'S PRIMARY PROGRAM FOR
DECARBONIZING TRANSPORTATION
FUELS BY DIVERSIFYING THE FUEL
POOL AND SUPPORTING LOW CARBON
TECHNOLOGIES WHILE REPLACING
FOSSIL FUELS. HYDROGEN IS ONE OF
THE MANY LOW CARBON FEEL
SUPPORTED BY THE L. THAT.
HYDROGEN FUEL PRODUCED FROM LOW
CARBON RESOURCES LIKE BIOMETHANE
FOR ZERO CARBON ELECTRICITY
GENERATES CREDITS UNDER THE
PROGRAM TODAY AND ON AVERAGE
HYDROGEN. VEHICLE FUEL HAS A 60%
LOWER CARBON INTENSITY THAN
GASOLINE AND IS 1100% CLEANER
THAN GASOLINE WITH REGARD TO AIR
POLLUTION EMISSIONS AT THE
TAILPIPE CARE RANDOLPH WE HAVE
YET TEN MINUTES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
WRAP UP THE SLIDE THAT THAT
WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. R. EIGHT THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THERE IS A
LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
VARIOUS COLORS OF HYDROGEN.
BROWN BLUE GREEN BUT WE CAN'T.
HOLD ONE TECHNOLOGY THAT COMBATS
AIR POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE
TO A HIGHER STANDARD THAN OTHERS
ANYTHING THAT IS CLEANER THAN
FOSSIL FUEL HELPS. AND OUR
TECHNOLOGY WILL INVOLVE EVOLVES
AND THOSE BILLS WILL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE EVEN CLEANER AS
WE MOVE TOWARDS OUR- FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO RANDOLPH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION- SO MEMBERS WE WILL
GO NEXT TO OUR SECOND PANELIST
TO IS COMMISSIONER PATRICIA
MONAHAN. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND AFTER THIS
PANEL WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS AND QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF EACH PANEL WE WILL WE
WILL BE PROVIDING OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBER QUESTIONS. WELCOME
COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE YOU MAY
HAVE THE FLURRY OF TEN MINUTES.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
WELL I WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS
TO CHAIR GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE ROLE OF ALTERNATIVE
FUELS LIKE NATURAL GAS
ELECTRICITY AND HYDROGEN. FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
AND EQUIPMENT. NOW THIS FEELS
ALL HAVE IN COMMON THE FACT THAT
THEY CUT HARMFUL DIESEL
POLLUTION AND HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO
MEET DEADLINES. THE WAY TO
STRONGER VEHICLE EMISSIONS
STANDARDS WHILE SHOWING THERE
ARE CLEANER ALTERNATIVES THAT
WORK FOR INDUSTRY. AS CHAIR
AROUND OFF HAS HIGHLIGHTED NOW
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO ZERO OUT
POLLUTION FROM TRANSPORTATION
WITH BATTERY ELECTRIC AND
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGIES. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BOTH OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ELECTRIC- SO
EV'S WOULD YOU KOW ACTUALLY
APPLY TO BOTH BATTERY ELECTRIC
AND FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
. SO THESE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES OR WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL
CENTERS ARE KEY TO CALIFORNIA
MEETING OUR TARGETS FOR CLIMATE
AND CLEAN AIR. AND FOR SHORTHAND
I'M GONNA I'M GONNA REFER TO
ZERO EMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES AS BIG SETS B. SO
BEFORE I DISCUSS THE ROLE OF
EACH OF THESE FUELS. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE RULES OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ARE DISTINCT AND
COMPLEMENTARY. YOUR RESOURCES
BOARD FOCUSES ON THE VEHICLE
INCENTIVES AND REGULATIONS FOR
BOTH VEHICLES AND FUELS. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION MY AGENCY
FOCUSES ON INCENTIVES AND
ANALYSIS. TO BUILD OUT REVEALING
INFRASTRUCTURE MAKE SURE THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
OUR TO MEET OUR OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION GOALS. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S PRIMARY SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION RELATED GRANT
FUNDING IS TO THE CLEAN TRACK
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM RECEIVES UP TO ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING PER YEAR THROUGH A
SURCHARGE ON VEHICLE
REGISTRATIONS AND SMOG ABATEMENT
SEES. THE PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
AUTHORIZED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RE AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND IS SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END
OF NEXT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE
. THE LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC
BUDGET INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT ONE SIX FIVE BILLION.
TARGETED SPECIFICALLY FOR SEVEN
STRUCTURE AND THAT
MANUFACTURING. THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS FOR SEVEN FOR
STRUCTURE. WITH OVER HALF
TARGETED TO EXAMS. IF APPROVED
THE PROPOSED FUNDING WILL HELP
US INCREASES EVERY FUELING FOR
BIG SAYS. AND WILL HELP LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES GET ACCESS TO
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. SO AS
CHAIR AROUND ALL HIGHLIGHTED
VEHICLE REGULATIONS ARE SETTING
A COURSE FOR ZERO EMISSIONS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. IN THE
VEHICLE MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY
IS RESPONDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE GLOBE. DAIMLER
TRUCK FOR EXAMPLE HAS SET A GOAL
THAT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES WILL
MAKE UP 60% OF ITS SALES BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND A 100% BY
TWENTY THIRTY NINE. LAST YEAR
EV'S WERE CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER
ONE EXPORT AND CALIFORNIA IS
RANKED NUMBER ONE WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT MANUFACTURING. WE ARE
THE NEW MICHIGAN WHEN IT COMES
TO SAYS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA'S ZERO EMISSION
PASSENGER VEHICLE SALES. EACH
THE HIGHEST EVER HAD OVER 12%
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PLUG IN ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
THREE THOUSAND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WERE SOLD LAST
YEAR. AND IN THE LAST QUARTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HIT THE
MILESTONE OF HAVING ONE MILLION
SAM SOLD. SO BIG SUBS ARE MORE
NASCENT BUT THAT SECTOR COULD
ACTUALLY ELECTRIFY FASTER WHEN
THERE'S A STRONG BUSINESS CASE.
WE KNOW THAT LAUGHTER OBSERVE
REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IS A
MAJOR BARRIER TO LAWS THAT
COMMERCIALIZATION WHETHER THAT'S
FOR PASSENGER VEHICLES ARE BIG
THAT. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES MY AGENCY TO CONDUCT AN
ANALYSIS OF TWENTY THIRTY
CHARGER NEEDS AND TO UPDATE THAT
ANNOUNCES EVERY TWO YEARS. WE
PARTNERED WITH NATIONAL LABS AND
MAJOR UNIVERSITIES TO CONDUCT
THE INAUGURAL REPORT THAT WE
RELEASED LAST YEAR. COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN. EXACTLY ESPECIALLY FOR
LONG HAUL TRUCKS AND HEAVY DUTY
EQUIPMENT. SB SIX FORTY THREE
WHICH WAS SPONSORED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND PASSED INTO LAW
LAST YEAR THE ENERGY COMMISSION
WILL BE CONDUCTING ANNOUNCES OF
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN
TWENTY THIRTY FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT WE HAVEN'T YET DONE
THAT ANNOUNCES. SO LET ME DIVE
MORE DEEPLY INTO THE CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES WHEN IT COMES
TO BATTERY ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC REFUELLING.
I'M GONNA START WITH BATTERY
ELECTRIC. SO WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THESE BIG
BATTERIES ON WHEELS TO INTEGRATE
RENEWABLES AND SUPPORTED CLEAN
GRID. WE NEED THE EXAMS TO BE.
THINGS THAT WERE HAVING A BIT OF
WIFI ISSUES BUT I THINK- SORRY
ABOUT THAT COMMISSIONER WE CAN
HEAR YOU NOW HOLIDAYS ON OUR END
HERE IN THE SENATE FLOOR WE MEET
THAT. BE SKIPPING A LITTLE BIT
BUT GO RIGHT AHEAD I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY SHOULD I START WHERE I WAS
OR DO I NEED TO GO BACK YOU KNOW
HOW LONG. YOU CAN GO BACK LIKE
ABOUT TEN SECONDS. IN SECONDS
ALL RIGHT- WELL- HYDROGEN I HAVE
. HYDROGEN AND OTHER ZERO
EMISSION BATTERY- OKAY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WELL I WAS SAYING
THAT HYDROGEN HAS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE TO PLAY AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING AN ANALYSIS OF TWENTY
THIRTY HYDROGEN REFUELING NEEDS
FOR BIG STEPS BUT WE HAVEN'T YET
DONE THAT. AND THAT WILL. SO I'M
GONNA START. TALKING JUST MORE
DEEPLY ABOUT BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLE REFUELLING. SO WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE BATTERIES
TO INTEGRATE RENEWABLES AND HELP
MEET OUR CLEAN GREAT GOALS WE
NEED BIG SENSE TO BE A GOOD
CITIZENS OF THE GRANT. ARE AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN REPORT
FOUND THAT EASY CHARGING FOR BIG
THAT CAN INCREASE LOAD UP 26% IN
TWENTY THIRTY COMPARED WITH
CURRENT STATEWIDE ELECTRICITY
LOAD. THAT'S A LOT OF FLEXIBLE
LOAD AND WE CAN USE IT FOR SMART
WE CAN USE THAT TO HELP. MAKE
OUR GRID MORE RESILIENT. WHERE
POSSIBLE WE WANT TO TIME THE
CHARGING A BIG DEBTS TO COINCIDE
WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY GENERATION
THE BIG SAYS CAN LITERALLY RUN
ON SUNSHINE. INTEGRATING
RENEWABLES PLUS STORAGE CAN MAKE
CHARGING COSTS LOWER AND THE
SYSTEM MORE RESILIENT. OUT ONE
OF THE PROJECTS WE FUNDED THAT
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IS A
TWENTY FIVE MAKE A LOT PUBLIC
CHARGING STATION FOR BIG SUBS IN
BAKERSFIELD. THAT INCLUDES A
MICROGRID INTEGRATING SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE. THERE'S ALSO THE
POSSIBILITY OF USING BIG SAYS AS
A SOURCE OF GREAT ENERGY. SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE FUNDED OVER TWO
HUNDRED ELECTION ELECTRIC SCHOOL
BUSES WITH THE CAPABILITY TO GET
ELECTRICITY BACK TO THE GRID AT
PEAK TIMES. AND NOW WE'RE
FUNDING PROJECTS TO TRY TO
UNLOCK THAT VALUE. SO A KEY
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF CHARGES IS THAT IT
TAKES A LONG TIME. UNDER THE
BEST CASE IT WOULD TAKE THIRTY
MINUTES TO REFILL THE VEHICLE
BUT MORE LIKELY WOULD TAKE MUCH
LONGER COMPARED WITH FIVE TO TEN
MINUTES FOR DIESEL OR HYDROGEN.
IN ADDITION THERE CAN BE
LOCALIZED DISTRIBUTION LEVEL
IMPACTS TO THE GRID. SO WE NEED
TO PLAN ACCORDINGLY AND ENSURE
THEIR ENSURE THERE IS CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH UTILITIES. NOW
LET ME TURN THE HYDROGEN
REFUELLING FOR- EXISTENCE. SO
LIKE CHARGING HYDROGEN FOR FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES PRESENTS
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
CHALLENGES. ADVANTAGES INCLUDE
OR DESELECT REVEALING EXPERIENCE
LONGER RANGE AND A LIGHTER
WEIGHT SO TRUCKERS CAN HAUL MORE
GOODS. THESE ADVANTAGES ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT WHEN IT
COMES TO LONG HAUL TRUCKS. THE
CHALLENGE AGAIN I THINK THIS IS
NO SURPRISE THERE'S A LACK OF
REFUELLING INFRASTRUCTURE. SO
TWO YEARS AGO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION EXPANDED OUR PUBLIC
HYDROGEN STATION INVESTMENTS TO
INCLUDE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
SHOULD GIVE US SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO REACH THE STATE'S
GOAL OF HAVING TWO HUNDRED.
WE'RE ALSO FUNDING DEEPER
REVEALING TO SUPPORT SIX
HYDROGEN REFUELING STATIONS FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
WITH THE FUELING CAPABILITY TO
SERVE ABOUT EIGHTY CLASS EIGHT
FUEL CELL DRAYAGE TRUCKS ABOUT
FORTY ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
TRANSIT BUSES AT ABOUT TEN
LOCOMOTIVES. AS OF TODAY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS
INVESTED A LITTLE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN HYDROGEN
REFUELLING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
LIGHT MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED MORE IN HYDROGEN
REFUELLING INFRASTRUCTURE THAN
ANY NATION IN THE WORLD SAVE TO
PAM. BESIDES A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE OTHER CHALLENGES
INCLUDE READING THE HYDROGEN
SUPPLY DRIVING DOWN THE COST OF
HYDROGEN. HYDROGEN SOURCED
SHORTAGES AND STATION DOWNTIME
DUE TO THE NASCENT NATURE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GREEN HYDROGEN WHICH WOULD BE A
NO REGRETS INVESTMENTS THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO EXPLORE HOW TO
SCALE GREEN HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
FOR TRANSPORTATION BUT ALSO FOR
ENERGY STORAGE AND OTHER. AND
OTHER PURPOSES. SO FINALLY I
WANT TO ADDRESS NATURAL GAS.
ENERGY COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF FUNDING NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES NAMES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN FACT WE
FUNDED IT FOR ELEVEN YEARS- FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROGRAM
UNTIL- FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN.
NATURAL GAS THAT'S BEEN A
CLEANER ALTERNATIVE TO DIESEL%
AND IT'S HELPED PUSH DIESEL TO
GET CLEANER. WHILE DEMONSTRATE
INDUSTRY THAT ALTERNATIVE FUELS
CAN CA PERFORM JUST AS WELL AS
DIESEL. BUT NOW IS YOUR RENTAL
HIGHLIGHTED WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEED THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION. WE'VE HEARD FROM
MANY STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THOSE REPRESENTING LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE FUNDING SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON ZERO MISSION AND THAT
IT SHOULD PROVIDE TANGIBLE
DIRECT BENEFITS TO COMMUNITIES.
THE CARD THE BILL'S REGULATIONS
THAT SET A COURSE FOR ZERO
EMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT ARE
FUNDING PROGRAMS PRESENT
INTEREST JUNCTURE ARE HELPING
INDUSTRY REACH THOSE TARGETS.
AND WE'RE STRIVING TO FUTURE
PROOF PUBLIC INVESTMENTS AND
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HARMFUL TAILPIPE POLLUTION. SO
IN CONCLUSION I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ZERO OUT EMISSIONS FOR OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS WITHIN
SIGHT. I'VE BEEN IN THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SPACE FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I'M MORE
CONFIDENT TODAY THAN I HAVE EVER
BEEN THAT THE FUTURE IS YOUR
MISSION. BUT I'M ALSO CLEAR I
THAT THERE ARE MAJOR CHALLENGES
TO OVERCOME INCLUDING A LACK OF
ZEBRA FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE BUILD OUT OF THAT REVEALING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO ENSURING CALIFORNIA
CAN MEET OUR TARGETS. AND TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HARMFUL POLLUTION. SO THANK YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AND YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION COMMISSIONER WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A NEXT MEMBERS WE
WILL GO ON TO OUR THIRD PANELIST
WHO IS MISTER ROSS BROWN
PRINCIPLE FISCAL AND POLICY AND
IT ANALYSTS EXCUSE ME WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
MISTER BROWN WELCOME THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S. HEARING IN MY BRIEF
TIME HERE I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY QUESTIONS
AND CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE AS IT EXPLORES. THE
ISSUE OF HEAVY DUTY EMISSIONS
AND THIS HEARING AND BEYOND SO
I'M JUST GONNA LOOK- JUMP INTO
THOSE THREE. KEY ISSUES AND
QUESTIONS NOW SO FIRST. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT- TO REMEMBER THE
HEAVY DUTY IN OFF ROAD VEHICLES
REALLY DO INCLUDE A DIVERSE MIX
OF VEHICLES EQUIPMENT AND
TECHNOLOGIES. BUT NOT LIKE A
LIGHT DUTY PASSENGER CARS WHERE-
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE SIMILAR
TECHNOLOGIES AND SERVICE SIMILAR
PURPOSE. AND HEAVY DUTY SPACE.
DIFFERENT STAGES OF
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT- AND
AT THE END OF THAT TECHNOLOGICAL
DEVELOPMENT COULD BE DIFFERENT
BETWEEN A TRANSIT BUS FOR
EXAMPLE AND LONG HAUL TRUCKS.
ARE SO AS A RESULT THE
CHALLENGES AND APPROPRIATE STATE
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES MIGHT
DIFFER DRAMATICALLY AND SO- THEM
IT'S NOT REALLY A KIND OF ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH- THE
SECOND. QUESTION AND I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE- IS
KIND OF THIS QUESTION ABOUT-
TECHNOLOGY INCOME WHEN TO BE
TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL IN WHEN
TO PUSH SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGIES
THAT. MIGHT APPEAR MORE
PROMISING SO FOR EXAMPLE
HYDROGEN AND BATTERY ELECTRIC OR
BOTH AND SO. UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK THERE'S NOT A SIMPLE
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION A DOZEN
BALLS- SOME TRADE OFFS AND
JUDGMENT. IN GENERAL IN THE
EARLY STAGES ARE WE THINK.
TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL
APPROACHES CAN GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY TO WIN- MAKES SENSE
HOWEVER THE DOES. IN MANY CASES
COME A POINT WHERE IT MIGHT NOT
MAKE SENSE TO CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN AND THOSE TECH CERTAIN
TECHNOLOGIES ANYMORE AND SO.
AGAIN I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
ANSWER BUT WE DO THINK THIS IS
A- KEY QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AND
PERHAPS. THAT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION OTHER PANELISTS
IN THIS. HEARING AT WHAT POINT
DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC TECH. HOW DO I HOW DO
AGE ABOUT THIS ISSUE OR CRITERIA
DID THEY USE. AND WHAT METRICS-
TO THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
INTEREST US US. THE THIRD AND
FINAL QUESTION I JUST WANTED TO.
HIGHLIGHT IS WHICH BUDGET ITEMS.
MIGHT THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
PRIORITIZE IN THIS AREA AND
AGAIN THIS MATERIAL WHERE THERE
ARE SOME IMPORTANT TRADE OFFS TO
CONSIDER. SO THERE'S REALLY
THREE MAIN TYPES OF. HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE PROGRAMS THERE'S
RETIREMENT AND REPLACEMENT
PROGRAMS LIKE THE KERR MOYER
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WITH.
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES ARE CLEANER
ENGINES WHICH TENDS TO BE IN A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH FOR
NEAR TERM AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS. THERE'S HEAVY DUTY
ON OR OFF-ROAD VOUCHERS LIKE
THAT EACH STEP PROGRAM WHICH
OFTEN GO TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. WHICH APPEARS TO
BECOME A MORE COST EFFECTIVE IN
THE NEAR TERM FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. AND THERE'S PILOTS
AND DEMONSTRATIONS WHICH- DO
MORE TO ADVANCE THEIR EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. WHICH CAN HAVE
RELATED MORE LONGER TERM
BENEFITS IN TERMS OF GHGS AND-
POLLUTION BUT MIGHT BE MORE
COSTLY IN THE NEAR TERM AND SO
THIS IS REALLY KIND OF LIKE A
KEY DECISION. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO PRIORITIZE
AMONG THESE DIFFERENT GOALS WHEN
A GERMAN IN ITS BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS AND LARGELY DEPENDS
ON. THE LEGISLATORS POLICY
PRIORITIES AND HOW IT BOUNCES.
SHORT TERM REDUCTIONS WITH A
LONGER TERM- DEEPER REDUCTIONS
IN THERE G. H. I WILL IN MY
COMMENTS AMONG THE TENS OF. HELP
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER BROWN WE PAY YOUR
AND WELL IN YOUR- THANK YOU.
NEXT MEMBERS WE OUR OUR FOURTH
PANELIST WHO IS MR MIA THOUGHT
TO WHO'S ACTUALLY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OFFICER. FOR SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT WITH
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THIS IS A
LATE SUBSTITUTE FOR- EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WIND MASTERY- MISTER
MINNESOTA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US. WELCOME YOUR THREE
MINUTES. OF THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE. US I'M DOCTOR
MATTHEWS- THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGIST
AT THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH IS THE
LARGEST AIR DISTRICT IN THE
NATION. IN AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
WE SUFFER FROM THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION MOSTLY DUE
TO MOBILE SOURCES. OF WHICH WE
HAVE ALMOST NO REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WE'RE ALSO HOME TO
NEARLY 67% OF ALL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE. AND OUR FAILURE TO MEET
THE IMPENDING EPA STANDARDS FOR
CLEAN AIR NOT ONLY RESULTS IN
UNHEALTHY AIR FOR ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS. BUT COULD RESULT IN
EBAY SANCTIONS TO CUT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING. INCREASE COSTS FOR
LOCAL BUSINESSES TO THE TUNE OF
ABOUT FORTY TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AN INCREASE PERMANENT
FEES. AND THE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
GO OVER OUR ERROR EFFORT. NEVER
MET THAT'S HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS IN
THE STATE OR DIESEL AND ABOUT
HALF OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR SO OUR INNER BASIN.
I JUST WANT TO CLEAR THAT WE
FOUR ZERO MISSION TRIP
TECHNOLOGIES ARE AS A-
COMMISSION MONAHAN SAID BIG
SAM'S- AND IN FACT WERE RUNNING
THE MOST ADVANCED PROJECTS IN
THE STATE IF NOT THE NATION ON.
ZERO EMISSION HEAVY DUTY TRUCK.
APOLOGIES MATTER KNOWLEDGE AND
TECHNIQUE ESTIMATE. IN THE NEXT-
TO GET TO THE VOLUMES THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR US TO REPLACE
THOUSANDS TENS OF THOUSANDS
FIFTY THOUSAND HER THOUSAND
TRUCKS IT'LL TAKE ABOUT FIVE TO
TEN YEARS AND THAT'S JUST TO GET
THE BATTERY OPTIMIZATION RIGHT
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE AS A
COMMISSION ONE HAD MENTIONED
THAT IN HEAVY DUTY FUEL CELL
TRUCKS OR EVEN FURTHER OUT JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE STARTING
DEMONSTRATION DOES TODAY.
INFRASTRUCTURE GRID SUPPORT
REMAINS CRITICAL A QUESTIONS FOR
BOTH OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES BUT
THE SAD FACT IS OUR COMMUNITIES
NEED CLEANER NOW THE NEAR ZERO
NATURAL GAS ENGINES THAT WE HELP
DEVELOP WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. ARE COMMERCIALIZED
TODAY THERE 90% CLEAR FOR KNOX
AND THEY HAVE ZERO A CARCINOGEN
CARCINOGENIC DIESEL PARTS THAT
ARE- WHICH IT CAN USE THAT
JURADO SHOWN HER MAPS THE
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE BY ALL
THE DOMESTIC TRUCK MANUFACTURES
THE TWO TO THREE TIMES LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRUCKS ARE BIG JOBS AND
THEREFORE TO FIVE TIMES
EXPENSIVE. THAN HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TRUCKS. SO INDEPENDENT
OWNER ON. NEED A FOR. CLEANER
OPTIONS OR THEY'RE JUST GONNA BY
USE DIESEL TRUCKS AND CONTINUE
TO DO SO. I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS OF FOR YOUR PLACE TODAY.
THEY'RENOT PERMANENT RIGHT IT'S
NOT A DEAD END WE'RE GOING AFTER
PLACES TRUCKS ANOTHER SEVEN TO
TEN YEARS AND BY THAT TIME.
THEY'LL GO TO ZERO EMISSIONS BUT
IN THE NEAR TERM WE SHOULD BE
REPLACING THESE DIESEL TRUCKS.
WITH 90% CLEANER TRUCKS TO HELP
IMPROVE REGIONAL AIR QUALITY AS
A AS A- IN ADDITION TO REMOVING
TOXIC STORE COMMUNITIES. SO LET
ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CANNOT REGULATE
OUR WAY OUT OF THIS IMPENDING
CLEAN AIR CRISIS WE JUST DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TIME ALL THE
SWEETER. AND TECHNOLOGIES ARE
REGULATIONS ENSURE ROUND OF
SHOTS. THAT SHOW THOSE AREN'T
GOING TO TAKE EFFECT ON TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. SO WE NEED TO
REPLACE DIESEL TRUCKS TODAY AND
WE BELIEVE THAT USING YOURS OR
NATURAL GAS. WORKS IN CONCERT
WITH ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. SO WE
NEED INCENTIVES FOR NEAR
TERMINUS REDUCTIONS WE BELIEVE
THAT SOME OF THAT BUDGET SURPLUS
SHOULD BE GOING TOWARD AND
CERTIFICATION FROM THE- A CHANGE
OUT OF DIESEL TRUCKS TODAY.
WHILE WE ALSO PAVE THE WAY FOR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCK TECHNOLOGY
AND PLANNING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE FUTURE. SO JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR INVITING US
TO PROVIDE OUR PERSPECTIVE. AND
BE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
MYSTERY AS- WE- YOUR TIME AND
YOUR PRESENTATION AS WELL. OUR
FINAL PANELIST IN THIS FIRST
PANEL WE HAVE IS MR JOSEPH TONA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER WE
HAVE A ROOM RURAL PERSPECTIVE TO
HIM A COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT-A MISTER TONY
. WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
MANAGER TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING YOUR ZERO ZERO
EMISSION. EVEN HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES RURAL AREAS. WELL
STATES MADE TREMENDOUS STRESS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR BEING SO
PATIENT ON OUR END WE'RE HAVING
AUDIO ISSUES SORRY ABOUT THAT
MISTER TURNER WOULD YOU MIND
STARTING ALL OVER AGAIN WE'RE
HAVING AUDIO ISSUES HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR BUT THANK YOU AGAIN
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT IMPLEMENTING NEAR ZERO IN
ZERO EMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES A RURAL AREA. WELL
THE STATE HAS MADE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES LOCAL SOURCES CONTINUE
TO BE THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR OF
EMISSIONS THAT IMPACT OUR HEALTH
BASED IN STANDARDS. OF THESE
MOBILE SOURCE EMISSIONS MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTORS.
KEEPING A MISSION PRODUCTIONS
QUICKLY FROM ALL SOURCES OF
IMPORTANT TO RURAL DISTRICTS TO
REACH AND MAINTAIN THEIR HEALTH
BASED. THAT'S BASED ATTAINMENT
GOALS. IMPLEMENTING YOUR ZERO
TECHNOLOGY ZERO AREAS ARE MET
WITH MULTIPLE DIFFICULTIES.
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY EASY
INFRASTRUCTURE IS RARE TO
NONEXISTENT RURAL AREAS. THREE
IN A ROW AREAS CAN SIGNIFICANT
REDUCED RANGE OF CURRENT ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY. AS AN
ANECDOTAL EXAMPLE I LIVE IN
REDDING CALIFORNIA IF I DRIVE MY
PLUG IN HYBRID NORRISTOWN SHASTA
CAN GET ABOUT TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY MILES OF YOU RANGE- SELF
THE SACRAMENTO CAN CHIEF ABOUT
FORTY FIVE FIFTY MILES OF RANGE.
A TOUGH OF OUR- BILLETE
DESTINATION IN RURAL AREAS SO
MUCH FOR THEIR PARTNER
COUNTERPARTS. FINALLY AS IS
COMMON WITH NEW TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE RURAL AREAS IS
OFTEN THE LAST VEHICLE. OTHER
CONCERNS YOUR ABILITY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES ARE
CRITICAL. OVER EVERYTHING VALLEY
COMMUNITIES HAVE SEEN A
REDUCTION IN. IN THIS
COMMUNITIES CONTINGENCY NEEDS
SEVERAL MULTI DAY WE CHARACTERS.
THREE THE REASON EXAMPLES YOU
MISTER NO STORM RIGHT NOW OUT
BROUGH IN THE SENATE AREA. PSP
IS A BETTER SHOT FOR WE- SIXTY
FIVE IN MINERAL HEALTH. I
RECOMMEND THE STATE'S SUPPORT
EXISTING YEARS ZERO HERE
TECHNOLOGIES. THIS TECHNOLOGY
SCHOOL FOR THE RE OF A ARE
HARMFUL TO HEALTH NEXT OF
REACHES ZERO MISSION TO FOR THE
IN THE DEMAND WERE YOU CASES.
IT'S TIME FOR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
. EXPAND THE ROOT COMMUNITY.
ADDITION THE FOR NEIGHBOR
DISTRICTS ABLE TO PERMISSION
REDUCTIONS QUICKLY THE YEARS YOU
MAY HAVE YOUR CALLED NOW DROWNED
WHEN HER DISTRICTS COULD BENEFIT
FROM THE THREE IS. IN ADDITION
RECOMMENDED STATE'S INVESTIGATE
THE BILLABLE TORNADOES ABOUT. TO
EVERY EFFORT SHOULD BE TAKE TO
SAY EXISTING BIOMASS. RESOURCES
ALSO TO BE THE TO THE OTHER LONG
TERM SYSTEM ALTERNATIVES
RESPONSE FOR IMPORTS WASTED YOUR. THIS ISSUE PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO THE BILL A THREE USES FORCING
OBERNOLTE RESPECT YOUR- USUAL
THESE TOOLS ALSO CO BENEFITS THE
GREEDY THE NEED X. BURNING IN
REDUCING FUEL LOADING ON ARE NOT
WORKING LANDS AND- THANK YOU
MUCH MR TO. WE YOUR YOUR TIME A
PRESENT AS WELL THAT CONCLUDES
OUR FIRST PANEL MAY ARE THAT
CLEAN. TECH BY EACH OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL- AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. WILL
HAVE A SENATOR DODD START START
US OFF AND THEN WE'LL GO AROUND.
TO THE MEMBERS BRIDAL. TRY TO
MAKE THIS QUICK MADAM CHAIR I AM
GOING TO SERIES OF QUESTIONS HOW
MANY. HEAVY DUTY OR BIG RIG ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS OR ON THE ROAD
TODAY. AND THEN I'LL JUST
THROUGH THE CHAIR- IT WHAT RATE
DO YOU EXPECT THAT THEY'LL
REPLACE THE CURRENT FLEET OF
DIESEL TRUCKS. AND THEN- WHAT IS
THE PROJECTIONS FOR THESE BIG
RIGS ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. OKAY LET
ALTERNATELY WHAT IS THAT ALL
BASED ON AND I'M I'M TRYING TO
GET A FEELING OF WHAT WHAT OUR
PLAN IS AND- HOW THAT ALL WORKS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SO I
DON'T KNOW WHO'D LIKE TO START
OFF- I KNOW TO RANDOLPH IS STILL
HERE SO I SEE HER AND NEEDING GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THE THREE QUESTIONS
THEY ARE CURRENTLY ON THE ROAD
IN TERMS OF HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
WHAT IS THE STRATEGY FOR DIESEL
REPLACEMENT AND THEN PROJECTIONS
BY TWENTY THIRTY. SURE SO I
DON'T HAVE A NUMBER FOR THE
ACTUAL NUMBER OF VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE NUMEROUS MODELS AVAILABLE ON
THE MARKET AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO- SORT OF TALK ABOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE USE CASE-
WITH THERE ARE MANY MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AVAILABLE. TODAY AND SO
THE RIVER A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
THINK TO THEMSELVES OH WELL I
CAN'T ICTURE THIS TRUCK DRIVING
TO MONTANA BUT MY POINT IS IN
MANY MANY MANY CASES THEY DON'T
NEED TO DRIVE TO MONTANA. 63% OF
THE TRACTOR TRAILERS IN THE
STATE TRAVEL UNDER TWO HUNDRED
MILES. SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
USE CASES NEAR COURT- HAND AT
WAREHOUSES- AND THE SHORTER HAUL
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
IS THEIR EMISSION VEHICLES. ON
IN THOSE SECTORS- AND THEY CAN
BE USED- FOR DRAINAGE AND FOR
OTHER SHORT HAUL- AND- ACTIVITY
AND OF COURSE- YOU KNOW DELIVERY
VANS- SMALLER AND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS. I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- ACQUIRES A
REMISSION TECHNOLOGY AND
ELECTRIFIED THOSE ROUTES WELL SO
WE REALLY NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT THE VARIETY OF USE CASES
THAT CAN GO TO ZERO EMISSION-
IMMEDIATELY AS WE ARE MOVING
MORE TOWARDS- OUR- AT. TWENTY
THIRTY AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE
GOALS. THANK YOU AT CHER
RANDOLPH WE APPRECIATE THAT ENDS
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
CAN'T FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DOLLY.
YEAH I WAS READING TODAY'S CREAM
BLOOMBERG GREEN REPORT THEY'VE
GOT. ARTICLE BY ASHOT RAFI WHICH
TALKS ABOUT UNDERESTIMATING THE
IMPACTS OF METHANE AND BASICALLY
SEBERG STANFORD GROUP HAS COME
UP I'M SURE THE MEMBERS OF CAR
BREAK. THEN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION UNDERSTAND THE
HUNDRED YEAR HORIZON THAT WE
LOOK AT FOR REDUCING CARBON AND
THEY SUGGESTED WHEN WE LOOK AT
METHANE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
A TWENTY YEAR HORIZON TO
RECALCULATE. THOSE THOSE
BENEFITS PARTICULARLY IF OUR
GOAL IS TO REDUCE. THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE EARTH OF THE
RISING TEMPERATURE TO ONE POINT
FIVE DEGREES AS SET FORTH IN THE
PARIS ACCORD RATHER THAN JUST
GETTING TWO ZERO- DINNER ZERO BY
TWENTY FORTY OF THE SHORT TERM
GOAL. IS THAT SO WITH THAT IN
MIND. THEN GIVEN THAT THE SOUTH
IS URGING. THE USE OF A NEW.
NATURAL GAS TO MEET OUR HEATING
CONCERNS AND ALSO GET THE
PARTICULAR. REDUCTIONS ISN'T. A
RECALCULATION NECESSARY GIVEN
THIS NEW SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TWENTY YEAR HORIZON
VERSES THE HUNDRED YEAR HORIZON
AS FAR AS THE PRIORITIES OF THE-
CARB. IN THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IS.
A SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT
WITH- WITH SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE
IMPACTS AND TACKLING METHANE-
EMISSIONS IS A KEY PILLAR OF- SB
THREE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND-
OF OUR OVERALL CLIMATE EFFORTS
AND- AND I THINK IT REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING HIS HEARING MISSION-
BECAUSE FOSSIL FUELS HAVE
METHANE AND WE NEED TO GET TO-
TO REDUCE THE IMPACTS. NOTHING
ON OUR CLIMATE. I'M SORRY CAN
MAKE A COMMENT THIS IS MATT FROM
THE SOUTH COAST. RIGHT BUT WE
HAD ENCOURAGE MORE A GREATER.
INVESTMENT INTO RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS IS THE QUESTION I
GUESS I UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM
WITH METHANE BUT SOUTH COAST IS
ARGUING THAT IN THE NEAR TERM TO
GET THE PARTICULATE MATTERS DOWN
INTO. HANDLE THE HEAT THE RISING
HEAT. RIGHT WE MAY COMPROMISE
OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE GOALS BUT
WILL REACH THE GOAL OF THE
PROMISE OF PARIS IS THAT THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE WORLD WILL
NOT. EXPAND EVER INCREASING
ABOVE ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CENTIGRADE. IN CENTER BY CASCADE
BELIEVE A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER MISATO WANTED TO JUMP IN
BUT I KNOW CHAPTER RANDOLPH ALSO
IS NEEDED AS WELL SO. BUT EITHER
OF YOU LIKE TO CHIME IN ON THIS
. I'LL JUST BRIEFLY NOTE THAT
YOU KNOW CAPTURING METHANE- FROM
THINGS LIKE LANDFILLS IS A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR OVERALL
STRATEGY AND THERE ARE CERTAINLY
USES FOR THAT RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS THAT WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD X.
THE EXPLORING. BUT I THINK AS AS
TECHNOLOGY INVOLVES WE NEED TO
BE UNDERSTANDING WHETHER
TRANSPORTATION IS REALLY THE
PLACE FOR THAT OR IF OTHER USES
OR THE PLACE FOR THAT. YEAH AND
I KNOW THAT COMMISSIONER MONAHAN
AND HER AGENCY DOES A LOT OF THE
G. SHE MODELING I JUST WANTED.
TO ADD THAT WE GET THE RENEWABLE
METHANE. AS A LONG TERM SOLUTION
AS I MENTIONED IT'S A SHORT TERM
SOLUTION UNTIL ZERO EMISSIONS
BECOME FULLY AVAILABLE. AND JUST
TO ADD TO RESPOND CENTER DOTS
QUESTION BUT THERE'S LESS THAN A
HUNDRED ZERO MISSION BAY EXAMS
ON THE ROAD TODAY. THANK YOU HE
SAID THANK YOU- SO APPRECIATE
THAT- DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR WHAT
HOUSE HE WILL GO ON TO SENATOR
DELHI. THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- MY QUESTION
IS FOR CHAIR RAND OFF FIRST I
WANT TO JUST. BACK UP TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE HAD A
EXECUTIVE ORDER BY GOVERNOR
BROWN. WHICH WAS FIVE MILLION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY WITH THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN SEVENTY NINE
TWENTY BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
STATUS IN A STATE LIKE ALL THE
100% OF IN STATE SALES OF NEW
PASSENGER ARS AND TRUCKS. WILL
BE ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. AND AT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES. WITH ZERO
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
WITH DRIED STRUCK TO MEETING
THAT GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
SO THOSE ARE EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED BY THE
LAST TWO GOVERNORS. WE HAVE THE
- WE'RE GOING TO TAKE OFF-
DIABLO CANYON WHICH IS THREE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF ENERGY IN
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T COUNT LARGE
HYDRO. IN RENEWABLE RESOURCES SO
MY QUESTION IS. IF WE'RE GOING
TO PUT FIVE MILLION JUST THE
FIRST EXECUTIVE ORDER FIVE
MILLION CARS ON THE ROAD IS
GOING TO INCREASE OUR NEED OF
ELECTRICITY. USAGE FROM ABOUT
FIVE TO SEVEN. SENT A SINGLE
FAST CHARGER FOR EIGHTY- TWO
FOUR TRUCKS WILL DRAW
ELECTRICITY IN THE AMOUNT OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED HOMES OR COULD
BE HIGHER ADDING CHARGING DEEP
OIL TEN TEN TO TWENTY CHARGERS
WOULD BE LIKE ADDING A SMALL
CITY SO MY QUESTION IS IF WE
HAVE ONLY A HUNDRED. WE HAVE
LESS THAN A HUNDRED ELECTRIC THE
TRUCK VEHICLES RIGHT NOW AND WE
NEED TO GET AROUND. FIFTY
THOUSAND. OUR HOUSE OUR GRID.
GOING TO SUPPLY THE ELECTRICITY
THAT WE NEED. BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE THAT'S FOURTEEN YEARS FROM
NOW. WHAT DID SHE AROUND UP
WOULD IT BE ALRIGHT IF I TOOK
THIS QUESTION SO CENTER DOLLY-
THIS IS PATTY MOUNTAIN ENERGY
COMMISSION AND- IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND IT'S ONE THAT WE
HAVE WRESTLED WITH- BOTH WE ARE
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR PARTNER
IN ENERGY AGENCIES AND THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN DOING A
REGULAR ANALYSIS- DEMAND
FORECAST OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED. NOT JUST FOR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
SIR BUT MORE BROADLY ACROSS ALL
OF OUR SECTORS AND THE THIS IS A
VERY ROBUST ANALYSIS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE- YOU KNOW
SET TARGETS THAT THE GRID IS
READY. AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
WORRIED YOU KNOW THAT IF IT'S
BEEN A ROUGH RIDE THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND ENERGY
AGENCIES HAVE REALLY WORKED
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT GOING
FORWARD. I HAVE THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF PROCUREMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE INCREASED NEED ON THE
GRID FOR TRESPASS LETTER CATION
BUILDING LET'S CREATION AND
OTHER PURPOSES- I WOULD ALSO
EMPHASIZE THAT. AS WE ARE
BUILDING OUT INFRASTRUCTURE.
ESPECIALLY FOR BIG. THERE IS
THIS OP. TO CAPITALIZE ON LOWER
RIVER ENERGY PRICES. AT THAT
STORAGE. AND CREATE A MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM. THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE INVESTED AND FOR
EXAMPLE IN SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSIT WHERE WE'VE- INVEST IN A
MICROGRID. THAT COULD REVEAL OF
THE THIRTY BUSES WHEN THE
GREATEST DOWN. AND WHEN THE GRID
IS DOWN USUALLY YOU CAN'T REFUEL
YOUR- INTERNAL COMBUSTION YOU
CAN'T REVEAL GASOLINE OR DIESEL
EITHER THEY RUN ON ELECTRICITY
AS WELL SO. THIS IDEA OF LIKE
WHAT HOW DO WE INVEST IN THE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR THE FUTURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED. THAT WILL
CREATE A MORE RESILIENT ENERGY
SYSTEM. AND. AND ALLOW US TO.
BUILD THE BUSINESS CASE FOR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT- GASOLINE
AND DIESEL STATIONS DO HAVE THE
ABILITY IF THEY HAVE A GENERATOR
BUT THIS LEGISLATURE OUTLAWED
GENERATORS- IN IN A BILL LAST
YEAR SO LOOK LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR ASKED. PEOPLE WHO OWN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO NOT PLUG
THEM IN BECAUSE WE WERE IN A
POWER SHORTAGE AND SO I THINK
THAT. THE FRUSTRATION FOR ME IS
THAT WE PASSED ALL THESE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY BEING
INVOLVED IN WE SET TARGETS AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA HOW TO
GET THE TARGETS- THIS EXACT SAME
THING. THAT WE SEE WITH THE
BULLET TRAIN IS SUPPOSED TO
REDUCE CARBON AND IT'S TEN YEARS
IN THE MAKING AND WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ONE FOR THE TRACK LATE SO.
LOOK THIS IS THIS IS DRIVING UP
THE WE HAVE 60% HIGHER
ELECTRICITY RATES. IN CALIFORNIA
THAN THE AVERAGE OF THE NATION.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES
HIGHER THAN WHITE. THEY DON'T
PRODUCE OIL IN HAWAII THEY DO IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE COST OF
LIVING IS DRIVING. CALIFORNIANS
TO LEAVE THE STATE SO I'M WHAT
I'M ASKING YOU IS. YOUR YOUR
TALK ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS FROM
NOW HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED AND I
CAN'T FOR THE I CAN'T FIND WERE
GONNA DO THIS OLD BATTERIES.
BATTERY'S STORAGE IS AND THEN ON
TOP OF THAT WE'RE TAKING OFF.
ELECTRICITY GENERATION WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ON THREE THOUSAND
MEGADETH DOLLARS JUST WANTED
SKEWS ME FOR INTERRUPTING YOU
HAVE A QUESTION YES THE QUESTION
IS ON TIME THE QUESTION SHE
ANSWERED THE QUESTION IS THIS IS
THE ANSWER I GOT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE THAT WE HAVE. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE MICROGRID JIM WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA DO WE HAVE
LESS THAN A HUNDRED TRUCKS I
WANT TO KNOW THE LONG TERM DOES
NOT TELLING ME HOW WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
AND I WITH THE ANSWER AND YOU
KNOW THE CHAIRMAN OF THE ERROR
THE- CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
. HAS A LOT OF POWER WITH THE
DIRECTING THE MONEY. THAT IS
COLLECTED. FROM THEIR RESOURCE
FOR- FROM THE FUEL TO. THE
CARBON ATTACKS. AND I'M ASKING
HOW WE'RE GONNA GET ABOUT TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE I AM NOT GOING TO
SATISFY. SAYS FOR FACTORY.
ANSWER BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ONE. BECAUSE THERE'S NO PLANNING
THAT'S THE POINT. WE NEED TO
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE INVOLVED SO
THAT WE CAN PLAN. FOR THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR REALLY GONNA
LEAD THE WORLD. IN THE ABILITY.
TO SHOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
REDUCE CARBON IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALL ALL IN WITH THIS LAST
STATEMENT. WE DO NOT EVEN
COUNTY. WILDFIRES WHICH IS THE
BIGGER. BIGGEST EMITTER OF
CARBON. IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
NOT EVEN COUNTED IN OUR CARBON.
EMISSIONS THANK YOU MATTER ALLEY
AND THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE
ACTUALLY TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT TO DO NEXT
AS THE LEGISLATURE. WE'VE GOT A
DEADLINE ON FRIDAY TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE BILLS THAT ARE
READY TO GO ON THIS VERY MATTER.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
SENATOR DOLLY- CENTER ARCHULETA
YOUR NEXT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
- I AM REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
HAVING US ALL HERE TOGETHER
TODAY AND I THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND ESPECIALLY ALL THE
GUESTS WHO ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY MY DISTRICT THE THIRTY
SECOND DISTRICT- IS MISSION OVER
INTO THE NEW THIRTY AT THE
TWENTY NINTH COMMISSION NEW
THIRTIES SO WE'VE GOT CHANGES IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
DISTRICTING BUT ONE THING HASN'T
CHANGED MY DISTRICT IS THE
NUMBER OF- FREEWAYS AND TRAFFIC
AND SO ON- IN THE EMISSIONS THAT
ARE OUT THERE IN THESE MAJOR
FREEWAY SIX MAJOR FREEWAYS.
THROUGH MY DISTRICT IS HAS LED
ME TO- PUT ON THE TABLE SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY THREE AND IT- ALL
OF YOU KNOW THAT IT THAT
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND COULDN'T A
CONSULTATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
PREPARE A STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT
THE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IN FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSIONS
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLES THAT BEING SAID. IT
CONJUNCTION WITH THAT I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ASK- COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN. IS WHAT IS. WHAT WHAT
IS CALIFORNIA DOING HOW ARE WE
BEING POSITION TO SECURE PART OF
THAT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL DOLLARS. THAT ARE
COMING. TO CALIFORNIA FOR
HYDROGEN HUBS. BUT THANKS CENTER
ARCHULETA AND THANKS FOR YOUR
BILL ACTUALLY I'M REALLY WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO DOING THAT
ANALYSIS I THINK IT'S A REALLY
GOOD COMPLEMENT TO THE AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN ANNOUNCES ON TV
CHARGER NEEDS THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY- AND AS I SAID IN MY
REMARKS I MEAN HYDROGEN HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY IN THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY SPACE IN
PARTICULAR. AND YOU KNOW SO
WE'RE TRYING TO DO ALL WE CAN AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOUR
RESOURCES FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO POSITION
CALIFORNIA TO BE- COMPETITIVE ON
GETTING FEDERAL FUNDING FOR A
HYDROGEN HUB HERE IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEFINITELY THERE'S NO
STATE THAT HAS DONE AS MUCH AS
WE HAVE. ARGUABLY THERE'S NO
COUNTRY THAT HAS DONE AS MUCH AS
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT FUEL CELLS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND
WE'RE LOOKING MORE BROADLY AT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE. OF GREEN
HYDROGEN A PARTICULAR FOR- TO
CREATE A MORE RESILIENT ENERGY
SYSTEM AND FOR SECTORS THAT ARE
HARD TO DECARBONISE LIKE
INDUSTRY AND AIR TRAVEL SO THE
SITE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
FEDERAL HOLIDAY. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS. FOCUSED ON
HELPING CALIFORNIA DECARBONISE
THE MOST DIFFICULT PARTS OF OUR
SECTOR- IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY
AND ONE THAT WE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO CAPITALIZE ON. I'D
LIKE TO GO VISIT HAS BEEN REALLY
LEADING SOME OF THAT ENGAGEMENT
EFFORTS- IN IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA LANDS THE
HYDROGEN HUB. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. I JUST LIKE TO FOR
UP MANY THAT. OBVIOUSLY THE
ENTER. THE TREASURE CHEST THE
BETTER I CALL IT THE TREASURE
SHIP JUST OF ENERGY INCLUDE ALL
FORMS. OF ENERGY N. AS WE'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT- ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WE ALSO HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT. A HYDRO CELL AND IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE GO FORWARD
THINKING IN THAT. AND AS THEY
SAID IF WE BUILD IT THEY SHALL
COME. INFRASTRUCTURE IS.
DESPERATELY NEEDED WE'VE GOT TO
INCLUDE THAT. IN OUR FUTURE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU CENTER TO LET AND WE
WILL BE HEARING A NEXT FROM
INNER PANEL FROM. THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH- WHO MAY BE ABLE TO
SPEAK A BIT MORE ON THE HYDROGEN
HAVE AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FIGURE THE PANELISTS-
AT LET ME BUILD ON. COUPLE MY
COLLEAGUES. REMARKS QUESTIONS.
MISTER BROWN MENTIONED. THE
IMPORTANCE OF TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY- AND THE WILLINGNESS
OF US AS A BODY AND I SUPPOSE
BEYOND US LIKE TO INCLUDE. THE
VARIOUS COMMISSIONS. TO MAKE
DETERMINATIONS AT WHAT POINT
DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO FOCUS. ON
A SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGY I GUESS BY
INFERENCE- TURN AWAY FROM
CERTAIN TECHNOLOGY SO-
COMMISSION MONTANA I'VE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT RECENTLY ABOUT.
HYDROGEN DIED IN THE STATE'S. AT
LEAST A SPOUSE POLICIES NEEDS
NEUTRALITY ACROSS BOTH PLATFORMS
FUEL CELL AND BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. AT BY THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THE REST OF
THE CREW THAT NEED TO BE MADE-
ARE MASSIVE- IF WE'RE GONNA GET
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY. WHETHER
LIGHT OR HEAVY DUTY. AT A LEVEL
THAT'S COMPETITIVE WITH BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES SO HOW DO WE
AS A LEGISLATURE AND ALL OF THE
BLOOD THROUGH THE SET TO ANY
DETAILS. THINK ABOUT. OUR ROLE
IN ALLOCATING FUNDS ACROSS IS
VERY LONG LEAD TIMES WHERE IT
MAY BECOME APPARENT. TO SOME OR
PERHAPS ALL THAT ONE. OR THE
OTHER OF THESE TWO PLATFORMS IS
NOT NO LONGER JUST TRIES
INVESTMENT. SENATOR NEWMAN-
WITHOUT DIRECTED TO ANYONE
SPECIFIC LET ME START WITH THE
L. A. O. AND THEN I'D I'D LOVE
TO HEAR- FROM. THE FROM CORPUS
WELL THANK YOU AND WE'LL START
WITH- MISTER ROSS BROWN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RELATED TO THE TECHNICALITY
QUESTION FOR MR US SENATOR
NEWMAN. YEAH SENATOR NEWMAN AT I
THINK IT'S- A GROUP OF A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND I
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK MY WRIST
MY RESPONSE WILL NOT BE. A
PARTICULARLY SATISFYING FOR YOU
I MEAN I THINK IT'S- THEY KIND
OF. WHEN THE KIND OF QUESTION A
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY AND KIND OF
WHERE DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
ARE- IS A VERY KIND OF TECHNICAL
QUESTION AND SO I THINK- YOU'RE
GETTING SORT OF THE INPUT FROM
OUR STATE'S ENERGY AGENCIES THAT
HAVE THAT KIND OF TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE I THINK IT IS-
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT THE- MAKING SURE
THAT KIND OF THAT INFORMATION IS
KIND OF GETTING BACK UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND HELPING SORT OF
INFORMED ITS DECISIONS ABOUT.
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS- AND YOU KNOW
AS YOU SAID FOR A VERY LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
ENSURING THAT THOSE INVESTMENTS
ARE STRANDED BUT ALSOTHAT THE-
THE STATE IT'S KIND OF
SUPPORTING SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
NEUTRALITY- WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT SO I APOLOGIZE I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND GIVE
YOU SORT OF A DEFINITIVE ANSWER
ON EXACTLY HOW TO DO THAT BUT WE
DO THINK THAT'S KIND OF AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO EXPLORE AND-
PARTICULAR EXPLODED MINISTRATION
. THEY ARE THEY LOOK AT THAT
ISSUE AND THINK ABOUT. IT GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MUCH OF. AND
JUST IF WE COULD ALSO FROM- FROM
THAT AREA. BORDERS ONE. THANK
YOU TO RANDOLPH SURE- AND- I'M
SURE COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN ALSO
HAS A LOT TO ADD ON ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL I DON'T EVEN KNOW
AT THIS OINT WE ARE MOVING AS
AS FAST AS WE CAN AND AS HARD AS
WE CAN TOWARDS A ZERO EMISSION
FUTURE AND I THINK WE'RE NOT AT
THE POINT YET WHERE WE SHOULD BE
TAKING OPTIONS OFF THE TABLE-
RIGHT NOW OUR AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS DO INCENTIVIZE- BOTH
HAD BATTERY ELECTRIC AND FUEL
CELL OPTIONS. AND AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAND THE PERFORMANCE OF
THOSE AND TO- INSURE THAT OUR-
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION GETS GREENER
AND LOWER CARBON- HAS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- SO I THINK AND I THINK
THERE'S STILL A ROLE FOR- UP ALL
TECHNOLOGIES AS WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE THIS TRANSITION. AND THANK
YOU CHAIR READ SO GOD CHAIR
MONAGHAN HAD DE I WOULD NOT PUT
IT TO YOU WHAT WATCH IT WOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT INVESTMENTS IF
AND WHEN THE STATE GETS BEYOND
THE CURRENTLY FUNDED HUNDREDS OF
LIKE TO THE HYDRANT STATIONS AS
WELL AS THE SMALL NUMBER. OF
MEAT MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
STATIONS WE HAVE. WHAT WE HAVE A
STATE GOAL HAVE TO. STATION OKAY
BY TWO TWENTY AND WE'RE
TARGETING OUR INVESTMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO REACH THAT GOAL- WITH
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE SHOULD
HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO HAVE
TWO HUNDRED. OPEN RETAIL
HYDROGEN STATIONS. THOSE
STATIONS WHICH AS I SAID
THIRTEEN. CAN HOPEFULLY MORE
WILL HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
REFUEL BIG SENSE AS WELL AS
PASSENGER VEHICLES- AND THAT'S A
GOOD POINT FOR US TO YOU KNOW TO
SEE HOW WELL WE'RE TIGHT
TRADING. THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
THE ACTUAL VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT SO
THOSE STATIONS SHOULD HAVE
ENOUGH. CASSIDY TO REFUEL CLOSE
TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT'S
NEARLY FIVE TIMES WHAT INDUSTRY
EXPECTS TO HAVE ON THE ROAD BY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SO THAT THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO SORT OF EVALUATE. DOES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED MEAT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN TERMS OF THE
MARKET- AND AS I SAID IN MY
POINTS I THINK YOU KNOW WE'VE WE
FACE SOME HYDROGEN SHORTAGES WE
FACE SOME. LIKE BREAKDOWN OF
EQUIPMENT THAT WAS HARD TO FIX
WHEN IT CAME TO THE STATIONS
THEMSELVES BECAUSE OF THE
NASCENT. NATURE OF THE OF THE
STATION TECHNOLOGY- AND SO AS-
THE MARKET EXPANDS. WE ASSUME
SOME OF THOSE ROAD BLOCKS ARE
GOING TO GO DOWN WE'RE WORKING
ACTIVELY TO OVERCOME THOSE
ROADBLOCKS BUT- I THINK THAT
THAT FOR US IS. IS A MOMENT TO
KIND OF EVALUATE WHAT WHERE ARE
WE AND- THIS WE HAVE REPORTS
THAT WE DO- ANNUALLY WITH THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IN CHARGE
OUR JOINT AGENCIES WILL. WILL
COME UP WITH SORT OF AN
ASSESSMENT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS ON
ON HOW WELL WE'RE DOING IN TERMS
OF MATCHING. INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THE NEED. I DO APPRECIATE AN
EXTRA CREDIT FOR USE THE WORD
TIE TRADING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN US SENATOR
ALAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
PANEL FOR A VERY INTERESTING
DISCUSSION- I YOU KNOW I'M I'M I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN KIND OF TOUCHING
UPON THE SOMEWHAT THROUGH THE
PANEL BUT- YOU THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF. WAITING FOR ZERO
EMISSION HEAVY DUTY TACK TO COME
ONLINE IN A SERIOUS WAY VERSES
NEAR ZERO EMISSION ANOTHER
PEOPLE FEEL REALLY STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS ON EITHER SIDES- I'D
JUST LIKE TO GET MORE- MORE OF A
SENSE FROM FROM FOLKS- IT MAY
MAY MAYBE THE MAYBE THAT THAT
THE GERMAN FROM THE- THE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THE
SOUTH COAST. I CAN JUST GIVE US
A SENSE OF HOW HE- THINKS ABOUT
THE WING OF THAT CHALLENGE- YOU
KNOW THE PERMITTING OF INTER
MINUTE OPTION OF NEAR ZERO HEAVY
DUTY TACK. MAYBE OTHER PANELS
MIGHT HAVE ADDITIONAL PARTS OF
THE ONE ADD INTO THAT THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU IF I MAY ADD
ON THAT THAT'S A QUESTION THAT I
HAD AS WELL SPECIFIC TO
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS- BECAUSE I
THINK THERE WAS A- STRATEGY
HORIZON THAT I HEARD FROM-
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OFFICER MISATO
ABOUT SEVEN TO TEN YEARS. WHILE
WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
SIMULTANEOUSLY SO. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW IF THAT'S STILL THE FACT IS
THAT IS THAT STILL THE CASE- AND
I THINK TWO. OF THE SENATORS
POINT AS WELL AS HOW ELSE WE CAN
BE THINKING ABOUT- THE- IN ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY- AT THE SAME
TIME BECAUSE I THINK OUR
COMMUNITIES DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE THIS IS ALL HEADED AND
THERE'S A LOT OF EVERYONE
PUTTING THEIR STAKE IN THE
GROUND AS ZERO EMISSION VERSUS
NEAR ZERO AND IT'S BECOME VERY
COMPLEX FOR MOST OF THE PUBLIC.
APOLOGY SENATOR ALAN FOR TAKING
THAT OVER BUT I THINK WE'RE ON
THE SAME TEACHERS TO THINK YOU
SO MUCH- MISTER MUSETTO. THANK
YOU. MADAM AND SENATOR ALAN
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. SO I
JUST WANT TO TRY TO MAKE IT
CLEAR IS THAT WE ARE COMPLETELY
ON BOARD. WITH THE STATE ON ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. BUT THE
SAD FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THEY'RE JUST NOT AVAILABLE IN
LARGE VYING SURVEIL OF ALL. IN
SMALL FARMS AND FOR THE SMALL
VEHICLES. RIGHT BUT IF YOU WANT
A BIG TRUCK PULLING CARGO AT THE
PORTS. IN ORDER TO GET TO THE
THOUSANDS OF TRUCKS THAT WE NEED
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME I THINK IT
COMMISSIONER MON HAD NOTED THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE TAKES TIME- AND
SO I YOU KNOW WE ARE A GREAT
STATE WE CAN. CHEW GUM AND WALK
AT THE SAME TIME SO OUR POSITION
IS THAT. WE SHOULD BE SAVING
LIVES TODAY. BY PUTTING OUT A
CLEANER TECHNOLOGY IS
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE IN LARGE
NUMBERS THAT'S ALREADY ROLLING
DOWN PRODUCTION LINES. ON THE
EAST COAST. WE CAN CLEAN THE AIR
WHILE WE PLAN FOR THEIR ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE. AND WORK AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT LOCALLY
BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IN THE PREVIOUS-
CENTER **** HOW SHOULD THEY
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS AND WE
BELIEVE THE FUNDS SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED. AT THAT PROVIDES
THE MOST EMISSIONS BENEFIT THE
BILL DECISION SHOULD BE HOW MANY
LIVES CAN I SAVE WITH THIS THIS
FUNDING. AND SO I THINK WITH
THIS GREAT SURPLUS WE SHOULD DO
BUT WE SHOULD PLAN FOR ZERO
EMISSIONS AT. TECHNOLOGY FUTURE
WHILE WE CLEAN THE AIR TODAY AND
LET'S NOT FORGET WE'RE UNDER
FEDERAL MANDATE I MEAN THESE ARE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES. IT'S A
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
FULFILL. SO EVEN THOUGH WE WON'T
GET ALL THE WAY THERE YOUR PLACE
EVERY TRUCK WITH THE END USER
TECHNOLOGY. IT'LL GET US PRETTY
CLOSE. AND WE'RE CLEANING UP
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW I DON'T
CHAIR CAN I ADDRESS THIS YES
PLEASE DROWNED OFF. THANK YOU. I
GUESS I WOULD NOTE A COUPLE
THINGS- I MEAN I THINK. WE NEED
TO BE MOVING AWAY FROM
COMBUSTION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE- AND SO WOW WE DO HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT INSTEAD DO SO
INCENTIVIZE NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE ARE AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE HIS
STORY INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE.
THAT WE FOCUS ON A FUTURE
WITHOUT COMBUSTION. AND I WILL
NOTE THAT NATURAL GAS TRUCKS DO
DETERIORATED PERFORMANCE OVER
TIME IN TERMS OF THEIR KNOCKS
EMISSIONS SO WE NEED TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND. THAT TRUCKS WE ARE
PUTTING ON THE ROAD TODAY WILL
BE ON THE ROAD FOR MANY MANY
YEARS TO COME. SO AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ALLOCATE OUR THE
U. S. THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
ABILITY TO ALLOCATE YOU WANT TO
BE ALLOCATING THOSE DOLLARS
TOWARDS THE FUTURE AND THE
FUTURE IS ZERO. THANK YOU CHAIR
RANDOLPH APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL
AS- WE HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION
FROM SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
KNOW AND I STEPPED IN A LITTLE
BIT LATE I HOPE THAT I'M NOT
ASKING SOMETHING ALREADY SHARED
BY TOP YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
HEARING HOW CONFUSING IT IS AS A
LEGISLATURE AND- AND JUST YOU
KNOW HOW COMPLEX THE ISSUE IS
AND I'M JUST COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I'M JUST. WONDERING I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROGRAMS WERE CREATED RECENTE-
CAN YOU DESCRIBE SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS FOR LOCAL COVER BANDS
THAT ARE TRYING TO TRANSITION
THEIR OWN VEHICLES- AND THEIR
SLEET OP WHAT. WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
ARE OUT THERE THAT YOU CAN
DESCRIBE. FOR THESE PROGRAMS FOR
FLEETS ARE. JUST IN. THE
GOVERNMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE A LOT
OF THE MARKET RIGHT NOW ARE
TRANSITIONING THEIR THEIR-
PUBLIC WORKS FLEET. ANYTHING
THAT THEY CAN SHARE. RIGHT NOW
WHAT ARE THEY WORKING TOWARDS
EDUCATING OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND BRING THEM ALONG BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL
MANDATES STATE MANDATES. NOW WE
HAVE THESE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
SOMETIMES ASKING FOR HELP AND SO
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW THEY'RE
BRINGING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALONG. YES AND THAT'S THERE'S A
MULTITUDE OF PROGRAMS BUT I.
WILL HAVE A COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN RESPOND. YES THE RUBIO
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION- ONE OF
THE- FLAGSHIP PROGRAMS THAT-
WERE FUNDING IS WITH A GROUP
CALLED CAL START THERE ACTUALLY.
OF SUPPORTING CARP ON VEHICLES
CENTERS IN THEIR SPRING ENERGY
COMMISSION ON INFRASTRUCTURE
INCENTIVES. AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. FLEETS LIKE
LOCAL LOCAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PLEASE AS WELL TO BE ABLE TO.
EASILY ACCESS FUNDING FOR BOTH.
THE VEHICLE INCENTIVES AND FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE INCENTIVES.
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE CAL STAR
PROGRAM SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
FUNDING- OPPORTUNITIES THAT
EXIST TODAY AND I THINK A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF HOW. WE'RE TRYING TO
GO FORTH WITH THE ONE GOVERNMENT
APPROACH I MEAN THERE RESOURCES
BOARD ANY ENERGY COMMISSION WE
DON'T WANT GRANTEES TO VIEW THIS
AS LIKE A CONFUSING EXPERIENCE
WHERE YOU HAVE. LIKE WIDELY
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS DEPENDING
ON WHICH AGENCIES FUNDING WE
WANT TO MAKE IT SUPER EASY FOR
DIFFERENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
FLEETS TO BE ABLE TO. YET ZERO
EMISSION REQUIREMENTS AND TO GET
THE REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
IT. BUT I HEAR YOU WE I MEAN WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE COMMISSION MONAGHAN AND
THE CENTER TO IT IF YOU HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION BECAUSE- WE'RE
GONNA FOLLOW UP ON THAT WOULD
AGREE QUESTION BY MY COLLEAGUE-
HYPOTHETICALLY A SMALL CITY IN
ANYONE OF OUR DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. CAN THEY OBTAIN A
GRANT FROM YOUR AGENCY TO- BUILD
OF A SMALL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THEN PERHAPS EVEN PURCHASE OF
SOME FROM VEHICLES TO BE A PART
OF THE CITY- TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. AND COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND-
RESPOND PLEASE YEAH I ARE YOU
KNOW GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
STRUCTURED TO HELP- BUT TRUCK
OWNERS AND I YOU KNOW I WANT TO
GO BACK TO MY TEAM ACTUALLY AND
REALLY DIVE DEEPER INTO THIS
QUESTION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT. I MEAN I THINK IT'S A
REALLY. IMPORTANT ONE YEAH WE
HAVE SPECIFIC TARGETS AROUND
TRANSIT BUSES SCHOOL BUSES
STRAIGHT DRAYAGE TRUCKS- YOU
KNOW BUT THAT REAL STRONG FOCUS
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT THEM
AS THEY- ZERO OUT EMISSIONS I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT ONE. WE
HAVE FUNDED AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THESEPLANNING GRANTS
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HELP
THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO- WE DON'T
THEIR PLANS FOR BUILDING OUT
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE FUNDED
SOME OF THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF
THOSE PLANS- YOU KNOW BUT WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO TO BRING BOTH THE
VEHICLE INCENTIVES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INCENTIVES
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD EXPLORE MORE
DEEPLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL OF THE FIRST
PANEL FOR WONDERFUL
PRESENTATIONS WONDERFUL
RESPONSES. I KNOW THERE WILL BE
A LOT MORE QUESTIONS AND WE'LL
CERTAINLY CHECK IN WITH YOU
PERSONALLY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M NEVER GOING TO MOVE ON
TO PANEL NUMBER TWO AND I
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE OF THOSE
OF THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP. A
PANEL TO WE'RE GONNA START OFF
WITH MISTER ANGELO LOGAN POLICY
AND CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR. FOR
MOVING FORWARD NETWORK. THANK
YOU TERRY DOLLARS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- FOR INVITING ME
TO CHECK I. YOU TODAY. AMANDA
LOGAN I AM WITH THE MOVING FOR
NETWORK WHICH IS A NETWORK OF
FIFTY FIVE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
COUNTRY WORKING ON. PRE
TRANSPORTATION MARMONTEL. I MEAN
JUST THAT. ALSO READ OF LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA JUST. GOING
FROM THE BOARD COMPLEX.
SITUATION TO TEN. ADDED HAVE THE
MONEY AVAILABLE AT WRITTEN OUT
BUT I HEARING THE- GREAT PANEL.
A KIND OF POP MUSIC KIND OF JUST
REALLY. IN TO SOME OF THE WHITE
REALLY HARD HITTING ISSUES.
FIRST I THINK IT'S CLEAR. THAT-
WE ALL UNDERSTAND. THE IMPACT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND WHAT- IMPACT
THAT HAS ON THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND ON LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND A
TOXIC EXPOSURE TO THE COMMUTER
ALONG QUITE FOUR DOLLARS WHETHER
ACTION NO LONGER SEVEN TEN
FREEWAY. IN BAGUIO LOGIN INFO
DIEGO. OUR WEST SPOKESMAN. NEAR
THE PARK OPEN. IT. CRITICAL THAT
WE TRANSITION TO A MEASURE. AS
RAPIDLY AS PART. NOT JUST FOR
RESULT IN THE COMING. BUT RESULT
IN THE PUBLIC HOW CRISIS THAT
ARE CA. ARE WHEN. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE TEN. HERE MANY THAT ARE THAT
THOSE. THURMOND SERIES OF CANCER
. AND ALEVE- ISSUES AS POINT. IT
FAT BUT TO DO THAT I LIVE IN
HAVE TO HAVE A- THAT FOCUSES ON
. WITH ASTHMA. THE GOAL IS THAT
WE ARE. THE NEED FOR SUCH ARE.
THAT'S GREATER THEY ARE. WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE ABOUT THAT
AND YOUR MONEY RESOURCES. ARE
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING THAT IS
PART. I DOLLARS BUT THEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE INVESTMENT.
THAT WILL BE MAKING OF THEIR
CREW INVESTMENTS ARE NOT JUST.
YOU KNOW STRATEGICALLY PLACED
AND PLANNED TO MEET PARTICULAR
OUTCOMES THAT ARE KIND OF-
FABRICATED IN SOME WAYS. I I'M
ALLUDING TO THE CLEAN AIR ACT IN
THE NEXT DOWNTURN THAT THE BILLS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE WE MEET THE LOCALS
AND THOSE REQUIREMENTS. BUT
THERE ARE CERTAIN POLLUTANTS
THAT ARCH I'M REGULATED UNDER
THOSE. THING FIVE CULTURE FINE
PARTICLES THAT ARE TOXIC BY PURE
. FIVE NATURE OF. THOSE
PARTICLES ARE IMPORTANT TO
ELIMINATE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NOT
REGULATED UNDER THE- THE
NATIONAL AIR AT AMBIENT AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS. OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE CLEAN AIR
THEY DESERVE ZERO POLLUTION AND
SO- MORE THINKING ABOUT THESE
INVESTMENT OF THE LIMITED
DOLLARS I THINK ABOUT WHERE WE
ARE IN TERMS OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE FREIGHT
CORRIDORS. AND IF WE WERE TO
THINK ABOUT JUST IN BACK IN IN.
THOSE CORRIDORS WITH THE
EQUIPMENT THAT MOVE GOODS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE YOU KNOW WE
WOULDN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
JUST INVEST IN THOSE VERY
LOCALIZED AREAS LIKE GRADE
STRUCTURE. LIKE LOCOMOTIVES LIKE
CARGO AND EQUIPMENT LIKE
CONTROLLING- SHIP EMISSIONS. MY
CONTENTION IS THAT WE REALLY
CARE ABOUT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WE CARE ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WE NEED TO INVEST IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES FIRST AND
FOREMOST MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
TO THEIR- POLLUTION. BECAUSE
THEIR ROLE- EMISSIONS AND
INTERNAL COMBUSTION
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN WE INVEST IN
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE LIKE
NATURAL GAS. AND WE SET UP A
FIFTY M. AND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
YEARS AND YEARS TO COME THAT IN
MY MIND IT'S NOT A TRUE
INVESTMENT. INVESTMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK AT THE
LONG TERM AND BY THE TIME WE
TRANSITION OUT OF. COMBUSTION
VEHICLES YOU KNOW THERE'S
GENERATIONS OF CHILDREN THAT
HAVE DEVELOPED AND THEIR LONG
HAVE DEVELOPED AND UNDER
DEVELOPED BECAUSE OF EXPOSURE
TO- CULTUREFINDER AND COMBUSTION. MISSION THE OTHER AREA THAT I
TO- PLAN IS THAT WE ARE. IN A
GROWTH PATTERN TERMS OF THREE
FOR. AND PRAY TRAFFIC WE SEE AN
EXPLOSION OF WAREHOUSE WHICH- AN
EXPOSURE OF THROUGHPUT THE TWO
WE IT. OF FREEWAYS AND THEM OF
TRUCKS THERE GOING TO OUR
NEIGHBOR. SO WHAT WILL ONE BASS
WE WANT MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT. ONE FORWARD INTO BACK
ESPECIALLY WE'RE TRYING TO
PRODUCTION WHEN WE ARE IF WE ARE
TO INVEST IN- NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES- AND WE ARE GOING TO
DEPEND ON THE PRODUCTION OF
NATURAL GAS AT THE SAME TIME.
OTHER ARMS ARE TRYING TO
ELIMINATE PRODUCTION OF OIL AND
GAS IN COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING
ONE STEP TWO STEPS BACKWARD.
THANK YOU MAY LOGIN AND IF YOU
CAN WRAP UP THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH WHAT THE- THE
- BACKING OUT SAY IT THAT'S
WHERE AMERICAN PUBLIC DOLLARS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE-
INSURING THE INVESTMENT IN ZERO
EMISSION THE POT. WAIT
AUTOMATION SO THAT WE DO NOT
ELIMINATE JOBS AT THE PORT CARE
ON THE DOCK AND THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PERPETUATING- THE- MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF DRIVERS- OF
GRADES TRUXTON AND WAREHOUSE
WORKERS AS WE INVEST PUBLIC
DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AS WELL.
NEXT UP OUR P. NUMBER. IS
HEATHER TIMELY THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
ENVIRONMENTAL PLAN. OF THE
DIRECTOR OF INVER PLANNING ME OF
LONG BEACH- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US MISS TIMELY.
WELCOME YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M HEATHER TIMELY
WITH THE PORT OF LONG BEACH. THE
POOR IS BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED FOR
MANY YEARS WITH OUR INDUSTRY
PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY ON THE
DRIVE TO ZERO EMISSIONS FOR BOTH
ON ROAD HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND
OFF ROAD TERMINAL EQUIPMENT. OR
IMPLEMENTING STRATEGIES TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
ALIGNMENT WITH THE STATE. I MEAN
ESTABLISH CLOSE TO GET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS FOR TERMINAL EQUIPMENT
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND TRUCKS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE LEVEL OF
EFFORT AND THE AMOUNT OF WORK
STILL REQUIRED TO GET. HERE TWO
MAIN AREAS OF FOCUS EACH WITH
THEIR OWN ST OF CHALLENGES.
FIRST DEVELOPING THE VEHICLES
AND EQUIPMENT. OPERATING
REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT FOR
TRADITIONALLY OPERATED MAN'S
TERMINAL EQUIPMENT AND ON ROAD
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ARE SEVERE.
THESE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
HAVE TO BE RELIABLE AND POWERFUL
WITH HIGH CAPACITY BATTERIES ARE
ADEQUATE FUEL STORAGE. AND
EXTENDED RANGE HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGIES HAVE PROMISED
THAT DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY FOR
OPERATE EQUIPMENT IS FURTHER
BEHIND. TODAY'S YOUR MISSION
YOUR CALL REPLACEMENTS THAT CAN
MEET THE RIGOROUS REQUIREMENTS
SUPPORT WORK AREN'T FEASIBLE FOR
MOST APPLICATIONS. WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING AND SUPPORTING
NUMEROUS PROJECTS TO ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES THAT TERMINALS AND
ON THE ROADS. AND PROJECT
PARTNERS HAVE LEARNED A LOT
THROUGH THESE DEMONSTRATIONS.
SOME OF THIS EQUIPMENT IS IN ITS
THIRD GENERATION AND IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE. BUT
THEY AREN'T READY YET. SOME
TERMINALS AND HANDED EQUIPMENT
BACK AFTER DEMONSTRATIONS
INCLUDE BECAUSE THEY DON'T MEET
THEIR OPERATIONAL NEEDS. WE
BELIEVE IT WILL STILL BE SEVERAL
YEARS BEFORE THESE VEHICLES ARE
FULLY FEASIBLE. AND LASTLY THE
COSCO ZERO EMISSION TERMINAL
EQUIPMENT AS AT LEAST THREE
TIMES THE COST OF EACH SO ON
AVERAGE. AND PROGRESS WELL
FINANCED INDEPENDENT OWNER
OPERATOR TRUCKERS. THEY'REGOING
TO NEED SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT GIVEN THE COST FOR ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS CAN BE TEN TIMES
MORE THAN WHAT THEY'RE USED TO
PAYING. SECOND BUILDING OUT THE
CHARGING AND FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARGUABLY THIS
WILL BE MUCH MORE COMPLEX AND
CHALLENGING THAN THE EQUIPMENT
DEVELOPMENT. INFRASTRUCTURE IS
EXPENSIVE AND DESTRUCTIVE HUMAN
STRONG. AND THESE TECHNOLOGIES
ARE STILL EMERGING THERE'S A
NEED TO FUTURE PROOF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ACCOMMODATE
FOR ADVANCEMENT SUCH AS HIGHER
CAPACITY BATTERIES AND- CHARGERS
TO COME ONLINE. A REGIONAL
NETWORK OF CHARGING AND FUELING
MUST BE BUILT FROM SCRATCH TO
SUPPORT THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PLUS ACTIVE DRAINAGE TRUCKS
SERVING THE SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS.
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
UTILITIES. LEN GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE ENDED WHEN THE TO PLAY
FOR AND DEVELOP IT AND WE KNOW
FROM. THAT DESIGN CAN CAN MANY
YEARS. EVER STRUCTURE ALSO BE
BUILT WITH ACT AND MINE. PUBLIC
CHARGING FUELING WILL BE
ESSENTIAL AND WILL REQUIRE
SUBSIDIES TO CONSTRUCT AND
OPERATE ESPECIALLY IN THE EARLY
YEARS. FURTHER RELIANCE ON THE
ELECTRICAL GRID NEXT TO SOLVE
HONORABLE TWO OUTAGES AND
REQUIRES ENERGY RESILIENCY
STRATEGIES. AND FINALLY
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW REGULATIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS MUST CONTINUE
TO PUSH FOR PROGRESS BUT ALSO
SET REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS SO
OPERATORS CAN COMPLY AND OUR
ECONOMY CAN CONTINUE TO THRIVE.
WE CAN ACHIEVING ZERO EMISSIONS
FUTURE WE REMAIN CLEAR FOCUSED
AND MAKE A DELIBERATE EFFORT TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
TOMMY APPRECIATED YOU ARE RIGHT
ON TIME AT THREE MINUTES SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE WITH US AS WELL-
NEXT WE HAVE. AT THE SUPERSEAL
SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR IN OUR DC
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GONZALEZ AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BUCKY SUPPORT YEAR WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY. ZEROCHAN VEHICLES ARE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ARE ALREADY GETTING OUR ROADS.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS IMPROVING BY
LEAPS AND BOUNDS. TODAY THERE
ARE DOZENS OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY ELECTRIC TRUCK MODELS.
EITHER AVAILABLE OR COMING TO
MARKET IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
MOREOVER MANUFACTURERS ARE
CONSTANTLY INNOVATING AND
IMPROVING THEIR PRODUCTS. AND
FLEETS WANT ZERO EMISSION GIVE.
THEIR SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL FUEL
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS SAVINGS.
BECAUSE OF THE SAVINGS MANY
ELECTRIC TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE
ALREADY COMPETITIVE ON THE TOTAL
COST OF OWNERSHIP BASIS. TODAY
I'M ONLY BECOME MORE
COMPETITIVE. AS BATTERY PRICES
DECLINE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
IMPROVE. THE TECHNOLOGY MATURES.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE SEEING
LITERALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PRE ORDERS AND PURCHASE
COMMITMENTS. FROM COMPANIES
INCLUDING AMAZON AND UPS AND
FEDEX. THAT'S THE VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFICALLY
FOR BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
MEETING THE CHARGING NEEDS OF
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
TECHNICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE AND ALREADY HAPPENING.
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS HAVE BEEN
UNLOCKED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
ENERGY COMMISSION PROGRAMS AND
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD.
MEANWHILE THE THREE LARGEST
ELECTRIC. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THAT SERVE ROUGHLY
THREE QUARTERS OF THE STATE ARE
PROVED TO COLLECTIVELY INVEST
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION IN
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TRANCHE OF FUNDING. SO THAT'S
THE GOOD NEWS BUT WE CAN'T CLOSE
OUR EYES TO THE REALITY THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES STILL HAVE
HIGH UP FRONT COSTS. MOREOVER
EXPLOITATIVE BUSINESS PRACTICES
THAT ARE RAMPANT IN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY SUCH AS DRIVERS
CLASSIFICATION. MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO UPGRADE
TO CLEANER TECHNOLOGY.
XCELERATED RAPID ELECTRIFICATION
INCENTIVES TO HELP FLEETS
TRANSITION ZERO MISSION ARE
IMPERATIVE BUT SO TOO ARE
POLICIES THAT ADDRESS BUSINESS
PRACTICES IT SHOULD HAVE COST TO
DRIVERS. ALSO NONTECHNICAL
CHALLENGES AROUND PLANNING
PERMITTING AND COSTS TO REMAIN
ON YOUR STRUCTURE SO. ROUGH TO A
GOOD START BUT A LOT MORE IS
NEEDED. HOWEVER PUBLIC HOWEVER
BECAUSE PUBLIC FUNDING IS SO
LIMITED WE SHOULD ONLY BE
SPENDING ON THE OUTCOME WE NEED.
ZERO TAILPIPE EMISSIONS NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES ARE ANTIQUATED
SECOND BEST SOLUTION IT SHOULD
NOT BE SUPPORT. IT WILL
PERPETUATE OUR RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS RESULT IN STRANDED
ASSETS AND INCREASE EMISSIONS.
PROMOTING THE SALE OF NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES ALSO PROMOTES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT RELIES ON.
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE ASIDE FROM
BEING RIFE WITH LEAKS AND
EMISSIONS ARE LONG LIFE CAPITAL
ASSETS MOREOVER NATURAL GAS
EMISSIONS OCCUR THROUGHOUT THE
FUEL SUPPLY CHAIN BEGINNING
TAILPIPE BENEFITS. LASTLY
PRELIMINARY RESULTS FROM AN
ONGOING TWO HUNDRED TRUCK
EMISSIONS STUDY SHOWS THAT
NATURAL GAS TRUCKS EMIT
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE KNOCKS IN THE
REAL WORLD IN THEIR LAB
CERTIFICATION RATE. AND THEIR
MISSION CONTROL SYSTEMS DEGRADE
RAPIDLY OVER TIME. IN SOME
INSTANCES CAUSING THEM TO
POLLUTE ABOVE THEIR DIESEL
COUNTERPARTS. IN COMPARISON
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE THE ONLY
TECHNOLOGY THE GETS CLEANER AS
THEY AGE THEY PLUG INTO AN
INCREASINGLY CLEAN ELECTRICITY
GRID. THAT'S WHAT GUYS VEHICLES
MUST NOT BE VIEWED AS A CLIMATE
OR CLEAN AIR STRATEGY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
WITH YOU TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PUT BRP. ARE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION AS WELL THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT WE HAVE THE
PANELIST A MISTER CHRISTIAN
MOTOR SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. FOR
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MISTER SHE MOTIVE FOR
JOINING US WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTIAN MOTOR WITH
A CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. GOODS MOVEMENT
IS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
INDUSTRIES SUPPORTING ONE THIRD
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND JOBS
TRUCKING IS THE IRREPLACEABLE
LINKING CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN
LEVINE OVER 80% OF ALL GETS LIKE
GROCERIES MEDICINES.
CONSTRUCTION AND MANUFACTURING
MATERIALS E-COMMERCE AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. TO MEET
THESE DEMANDS TRUCKERS DEPLOYED
THE FIRST SET OF VEHICLES
SERVING DOZENS OF UNIQUE USE
CASES INCLUDED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S MATERIALS IS A CHART
WHICH OUTLINES THE BROAD RANGE
OF TRUCKS USED IN THE INDUSTRY.
CLASS TO BE CARGO VANS TO LARGE
CLASS EIGHT TRACTORS AT THE
STATE CONSIDERS A TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS WE
RECOMMEND FOCUSING ON THOSE USE
CASES BEST SUITED FOR TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY. SPECIFICALLY SMALLER
CLASS TO BE THREE FIVE VEHICLES
THAT RETURNED TO A CENTRALIZED
LOCATION AND CAN CHARGER FUEL
OVERNIGHT. AS BATTERING VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES THIS TYPE OF
OPERATION PRIMARILY FOUND IN THE
FINAL MILE DELIVERY SPACE SHOULD
OVERCOME MANY OF THE BARRIERS
POSED BY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY NAMELY LIMITED RANGE
INCREASE WEIGHTS LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CHARGING
DOWNSIDE. FONG FINAL MILE
DELIVERY VEHICLES TYPICALLY
OPERATE LOCALLY RUN OUT OF CARGO
SPACE BEFORE WAIT YOU CAN
UTILIZE THE PRO CHARGING OVER AN
EIGHT TO TEN HOUR PERIOD WHICH
LESSENS GREAT IMPACT. FOR LARGER
CLASS SEVENTY TRACTORS WILL BE
MORE DIFFICULT TO OVERCOME THESE
LIMITATIONS. TRACTORS REGULARLY
TRAVEL IN EXCESS OF THREE
HUNDRED MILES PER DAY EXCEEDING
THE RANGE OF TODAY'S ELECTRIC
TRUCKS BATTERIES CAN ADDED SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND POUNDS TO THE
WEIGHT OF A TRACTOR REDUCING
CARGO CAPACITY BY FIFTEEN
PERCENT. THE GREAT IMPACT OF
CLASS SEVEN EIGHT TRACTORS WILL
ALSO BE MUCH GREATER IN THE
COMMITTEES MATERIALS IS A
COMPARISON BETWEEN THE POWER
DRAW FINAL MILE DELIVERY
VEHICLES AND LARGER TRUCKS.
ENERGY COMMISSION HAS ESTIMATED
THAT THE SIXTEEN THOUSAND CLASS
EIGHT TRACTORS SERVING SEVEN
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ALONE. COULD
GENERATE UP TO A GIGGLE WATER
PEAK LOAD. THESE TRUCKS COMPRISE
JUST SIX AND A HALF ASCENT OF
THE S. THE MILES. BY SEVEN EIGHT
TRUCKS AND STAY. ALSO COMMON
FLEETS OPERATE FOR LEAST. MAKING
ALL TERM MARGIN. IN CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE MORE DIFFICULT.
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE CHARGING
COULD FILL THIS GAP BUT IT
TODAY'S CHARGING SPEEDS IT COULD
TAKE ANYWHERE FROM BETWEEN ONE
AND A HALF TO FOUR HOURS. THE
CHARGER TRUCK IN THOUSANDS OF
MULTIPLE MEGAWATT STATIONS WOULD
NEED TO BE CONSTRUCTED. IN
SUMMARY CLASS SEVEN ELECTRIC
TRUCKS CAN WORK IN CERTAIN
RETURN TO BASE OPERATIONS BUT
THAT WILL BE THE EXCEPTION
RATHER THAN THE RULE UNTIL
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES OR
OTHER OPTIONS SUCH AS HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL VEHICLES EMERGE. A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE FIRST OF CALIFORNIA
MUST FOCUS ON BUILDING A ZERO
EMISSION FINAL MILE DELIVERY
MARKET. EVEN WITH THE ADVANTAGES
HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER THIS WILL BE
A MAJOR UNDERTAKING FOR INSTANCE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE COST. JOBS
FOR CLASS TO BE IN THREE TRUCKS
ALONE COULD BE FIVE TO TEN
BILLION DOLLARS BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. PERSON STATE CARDS ENTIRE
AND BUS RADIAL. WHICH REDUCE THE
PARTICULATE MATTER BY OVER 99%
BY TURNING OVER A MILLION
VEHICLES. POSHEST TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. SECOND ENSURE
ACCESS TO TAXPAYER FUNDED-PROGRAMS FOR ALL FLEETS. IN
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR CARB
RESTRICTED- FLEETS OF FIFTY OR
MORE TRUCKS FOR PARTICIPATING IN
A TRAP. THE STATE'S LARGEST
ELECTRIC TRUCK INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. THIS DECISION WILL
DELAY THE STATE FROM ACHIEVING
ITS ZERO EMISSION GOALS AND
SHOULD BE REPRESENTED AS THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THANKS AGAIN TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SHIMODA WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. FINAL PANELIST AND
AN PANEL NUMBER TWO IS MISS
JESSICA DURHAM PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR THE LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR
A NEW ECONOMY WELCOME. THANK YOU
TERRY GONZALEZ AND TO ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA DURHAM AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COURTS PROJECT
THAT LANE. WHERE WE WORK TO
PROMOTE CLEAN AIR GOOD JOBS AND
HELP THE COMMUNITY. CAMPAIGN WE
PARTNER WITH THE TEAMSTERS FOR
YEARS TO TRANSFORM THE PORT
TRUCKING INDUSTRY THE COURTS OF
THE LAND LONG BEACH. FOR DECADES
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS AND
COMMUNITIES SUFFERED FROM THE
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES. CREATED
BY AN UNACCOUNTABLE INDUSTRY.
DELHI POLLUTION AND EXPLOITATIVE
WORKING CONDITIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WE JOIN WITH OUR
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL PARTNERS
TACKLE THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
POVERTY INCLUSION OF THE PORTS.
INDUSTRY SYSTEMIC CLASSIFICATION
OF DRIVER IS AS CLOSE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. WHEN IS
CLASSIFIED CHECKING NOT ONLY
UNLAWFUL DEPRIVED DRIVERS. RIGHT
RIGHT FROM PROTECTIONS ALSO
UNLAWFULLY FORCED TRUCK BECAUSE
ON THE BACKS OF THE SAME DRIVERS
TWO YEARS AGO WE ADVOCATED WITH
OUR COALITION PARTNERS FOR CLEAN
TRUCK PROGRAM AT THE FOR THE
LANDMARK BEACH THAT WOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE ADDRESSING THE
UNDERLYING BUSINESS MODEL AND
ENSURING THAT THE INDUSTRY WOULD
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE FOR
THE TRANSITION. UNFORTUNATELY
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY CHALLENGE
THAT POST IN THE COURTS.
ULTIMATELY GETTING IT. LEFT US
WITH A MANDATE FOR NEW CONTRACTS
WITH NO DRIVER PROTECTIONS
COMPANIES PASSED THE BUILDING
DRIVERS. AND THE RESULTING WAGE
THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN BY THE
LEGAL SYSTEM INCLUDING OVER FIVE
HUNDRED LABOR COMMISSIONER AND
COURT DECISIONS. AND WAS
DOCUMENTED BY USA TODAY AS
MODERN DAY INDENTURED SERVITUDE
. WHAT EXPERIENCE TELLS US IS
THAT IF THE UNDERLYING ISSUE OF
DRIVERLESS CLASSIFICATION IS NOT
ADDRESSED THEN WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO REACH OUR MISSION- NOT
ONLY WOULD BE IMMORAL PRINCE TO
YET AGAIN FORCED DRIVERS TO BEAR
THAT BURDEN. IT'S ALSO
UNSUSTAINABLE. REPORTS MOST
RECENT DATA SHOW THAT THE
EMISSIONS GAINES IN THE FIRST
CONTRACT PROGRAMMER RECEIVING A
TREND THAT BEGAN WELL BEFORE THE
RECENT CONGESTION THIS IS PARTLY
BECAUSE DRIVERS CAN AFFORD
UPGRADES OR EVEN OFF AND REPAIR
. READ STORIES OF DRIVERS IN
DIESEL ENGINES IN THE LNG TRUCK
BECAUSE THEY WERE DROWNING IN
REPAIR BILLS. ANECDOTES ARE BORN
OUT OF CARDS OWN DATA WHICH
OTHER TRUCKS IN THE SO CALLED
CONTRACTING SEGMENT HAVE THE
LOWEST COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATE'S TRUCK COMBUSTIBLE. IS
WE'VE HEARD YOU THEIR MISSION
TRUCK CAN COST TEN TIMES MORE.
SO TO THE POINT THAT INDEPENDENT
CON INDEPENDENT OWNER OPERATORS
WILL NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE MOST IF
NOT ALL HE SAYS THAT WE SUPPORT
USED TRUCK OWNERS ARE IN FACT
EMPLOYEES UNDER THE LAW. AS A
LEGAL SYSTEM SYSTEM HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY FOUND. NOT ONLY
UNSUSTAINABLE FOR THEIR
EMPLOYERS THE PAST TRUCK COSTS
ON TO THEM IT'S ILLEGAL WE MUST
ENSURE THAT OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS
ARE NOT. USED YET AGAIN TO FORCE
DRIVERS AND THE PUBLIC PREDATORY
LOANS AN INDENTURED SERVITUDE.
WERE DISTURBING PUBLIC FUNDS TO
PRIVATE INDUSTRY THAT HAS REAPED
RECORD PROFITS BREADED THAT THEY
COULD NOT MAKE. WE MUST MAKE
SURE THAT AND SEVEN DOLLARS AND
THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE STANDARDS
ATTACHED BUT IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY AND LABOR STANDARDS
FOR DRIVERS. REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEIR MISSION I
WANT TO ECHO THE POINTS RAISED
BY ANGELA BUT HE FEELS REGARDING
THE LABOR STANDARDS WE MUST
ENSURE FULL IMPLEMENTATION AND
VIGOROUS ENFORCEMENT OF AB SEVEN
NINE FOUR. AND IF THE THREE
THREE EIGHT AND A HUGE THANK YOU
TO SENATOR SILENCE FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN RAISING THE
STANDARDS. WE ALSO NEED MORE
STRATEGIC COMPREHENSIVE
ENFORCEMENT BY STATE AGENCIES TO
ROOT OUT THE CLASSIFICATION OF
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY. ONE LAST
POINT ABOUT A PAYMENT THAT WHEN
EMPATHIZE ELECTRIFICATION SHOULD
NOT MEAN AUTOMATION VERY OFTEN
THE INDUSTRY USES THIS ISSUE TO
CREATE A FALSE DICHOTOMY AND PET
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INTERESTS. AGAINST EACH OTHER WE
CAN WE SHOULD TRANSITION OUR-
AND ELECTRIFICATION. BY
MAINTAINING THE GOOD UNION JOBS
WE HAVE IN THE GOOD FOR THAT
SECTOR AND FUELING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A MARKET
JOBS SOME CLOTHING AS LONG AS
THE INDUSTRY. THAT OUR COURTS.
BEYOND UP OUT OPERATE OUTSIDE OF
THE LAN WITH AN ILLEGAL BUSINESS
MODEL IF THE CLASSIFICATION. IT
WILL CONTINUE. TO HINDER OUR
EFFORTS TO BE TRANSITION. BUT
THE BILL OF DOLLARS IN THE
CENTER FUND THAT WILL GOING TO
THAT KIND. WE HAVE A REAL UP. TO
TRY. COURT INTO HIGH AND THE-
AND THE LEFT THE DRIVE. AND
FRONT LIKE COMMUNITY. THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
I'M WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
AND TIME IS WELL. THAT COULD.
OUR TO OUR STAKEHOLDER PANEL-
AND WILL NOW TAKE IT TO THE
FLOOR FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM
SENATORS ON THIS PANEL- WE HAVE
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I HAVE A QUESTION WHAT
DOES IT COST TO- TO CHARGE- WHEN
THESE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. THAT
DIRECTED TO ANY SPECIFIC US
ANALYST YEAH WELL I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE THAT'S THE THINK- IS
TIMELY IS GOING OFF MUTINOUS
TIMELY WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER.
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBERS BUT THAT'S PART OF
WHAT WE'RE GATHERING THROUGH THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN CONDUCTING THERE'S A
LOT OF UNKNOWNS ABOUT THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT IT MEANS TO
CHARGE THEM- AND- QUITE FRANKLY.
THE TIME THAT YOU CHARGE THEM
HOW MANY YOU HAVE CHARGING AT
THE SAME TIME THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT GO INTO
YOU THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH IT
BUT THE DEMONSTRATIONS WERE
DOING ARE TO HELP US GATHER THAT
INFORMATION SO WE CAN MAKE
BETTER PROJECTIONS. ABOUT WHAT
THE COST WILL BE BUT ALSO WHAT
TYPE OF INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
OUT SO THAT WE CAN CONDUCT THE
OPERATIONS IN A WAY THAT CAN
SUPPORT- THAT THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES THAT WE NEED TO BE
CHARGED THIRTY WILL
SIMULTANEOUSLY. THE FOLLOW
QUESTION ANSWER IT. I DON'T KNOW
WHO MENTIONED IT BUT ONE OF ONE
OF THE PANELISTS MENTIONED THE
COST OF THE TRUCK COULD BE TEN
TIMES AS MUCH AS A CONVENTIONAL
. TRUCK IS THAT WAS THAT WAS
THAT WAS AN ACCURATE. SO I THINK
I MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS AND
NETWORK WHEN I'M TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THERE IS NOT NECESSARILY
THAT A BRAND NEW ZERO EMISSIONS
TRUCK IS TEN TIMES MORE THAN A
BRAND NEW DIESEL TRUCK. DATE
THAT WE HAVE IS THE MAJORITY OF
FOLKS AND I THINK CHRIS COULD
PROBABLY ANSWER THIS A LITTLE
BIT MORE DIRECTLY THE MORE
MAJORITY OF THE FOLKS TO
PARTICIPATE AND PORT DRAINAGE
ARE PURCHASING BRAND NEW TRUCKS
RIGHT OFF THAT IS THOUGH NOT
THEIR PURHASING USED TRUCKS
THAT ARE MUCH CHEAPER. FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO BED THAT
IS SERVICE AND SO TRYING TO ASK
THOSE FOLKS TO GET INTO A BRAND
NEW ELECTRIC OR FUEL CELL TRUCK
IS A BIG LEAP FROM WHAT THEY ARE
TYPICALLY USED TO PAYING. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ASK ANOTHER
CLEAR RESTAURANTS COULD ANSWER
THAT'D BE GREAT BECAUSE I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. YEAH WE DO
WE THE LAST TIME I WAS TALKED
ABOUT. YOU KNOW BASICALLY LABOR
ISSUES AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS- THAT. I'D
LIKE TO KIND OF GET AN IDEA OF
WHAT I MEAN WE'VE SEEN. WE'VE
SEEN THE PORTS CONGESTED IN IN
IS THAT DUE TO THE FACT THAT
THE- MISSIONS ARE HAVE BEEN
THERE OR THAT THEY CAN AFFORD
THE TRUCKS OR IS IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WHO
HAVE. CAN'T COME IN THERE. HERE
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO THE INDUSTRY I MEAN
WANT ONE OF THE REASONS WHY. I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW THESE LARGER
FLEETS ARE BEING EXCLUDED FROM
THE STATE'S INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
IS THAT. IT'S REALLY THOSE LARGE
MEDIUM SIZE FLEETS THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL. TO MAKE
THESE INITIAL INVESTMENTS TO
BUILD THIS MARKET WHERE I THINK
IN THE CHOIR PANEL. THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THERE'S FEWER
THAN A HUNDRED. ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD TODAY AND
SO- THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY AT
LARGE I MEAN. SETTING ASIDE THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR ISSUE.
96% OF THE TRUCKING COMPANIES
NATIONALLY OPERATE TWENTY OR
FEWER TRUCKS AND SO DID THIS IS
A SMALL BUSINESS. MOM AND POP
ORIENTED INDUSTRY TO BEGIN WITH.
ARE WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW LARGER
INDUSTRY LEADERS CAN GET. STATE
SUPPORT TO- YOU KNOW REALLY TAKE
THAT THE FIRST STEP IN THE WATER
WITH THESE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WORK- AND
THEN. REALLY YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY
OVER TIME AS THE TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVES THESE MARKETS WILL
BUILD ON THEIR OWN- AS BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES AND ACTUALLY
FIGURE OUT. YOU KNOW HOW T
INTEGRATE THIS. INTO THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY OR SEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY I DO HAVE A
QUESTION I THINK THE L. DIRECT
THIS TO MISS TOMMY. I THINK
THERE WAS A QUESTION PRIOR ABOUT
A TWO BILLION DOLLARS
POTENTIALLY FOR A HYDROGEN HUB-
IN LOCKPORT OF LONG BEACH. PORT
ST PETER- BAY CAN YOU TOUCH ON
THAT A BIT AND WHAT. I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY UPDATES ON
THAT AND- YOU KNOW THAT WILL
CERTAINLY FURTHER ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS BUT WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT AND THEN I
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION RELATED
TO. THE CONTAINER FEE. SURE I
CAN PROVIDE A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS. AND WE'RE VERY WE'RE
ALSO TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT WE'RE ALSO OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES IN THE FUTURE
FOR HYDROGEN. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH UC IRVINE FOR MANY YEARS AS
A PART OF OUR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS. FOCUSED ON YOUR
MISSION AND MY GIRLFRIENDS. AND
AT UC IRVINE- APPROACHED US
ABOUT PREPARING OUR RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN ROAD MAP FOR THAT RIGHT
TO SAN PEDRO BAY. SO THAT WE
COULD DO YOU A LOT OF THE
IMPORTANT PLANNING AND
FORECASTING WORK TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- HOW HYDROGEN COULD
HELP. TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEIR OUR DRIVE TO GET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS AND SHOW. THAT
ROADMAP. WORK IS UNDER WAY AND
REYES OUT AT A PLAN TO HELP US-
ABOUT THE INITIAL PLANNING AND
THEN UNDERSTAND OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS WHAT IT WILL TAKE.
TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP MORE
HYDROGEN TO SUPPORT YOUR MISSION
OPERATIONS AT THAT IN THE GOODS
MOVEMENT SECTOR AND. THAT THE
PORT SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER PRE THAT AND I UNDER YOU
KNOW THIS IS. THERE THE
CONTAINER FEE HAS BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
MULTIPLE TIMES OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS PLUS PLUS- BUT JUST IN
RECENT TIMES RELATED TO PORT
CONGESTION. AND SO CAN YOU GIVE
US AN UPDATE ON WHERE WE'RE AT I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER CONTAINER FEE HOPEFULLY
IMPOSED IN APRIL- THOSE DOLLARS
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND WOULD GO
BACK TOWARD THE CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM SO WOULD LOVE TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT. WHERE WE'RE AT AND
HOW WE CAN FURTHER EXACERBATE-
THE NEED FOR CLEANER AIR HERE IN
THE- SOUTH COAST REGION.
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD THERE ARE
ACTUALLY TWO DIFFERENT- CHARGES.
THAT ARE. BEING DISCUSSED RIGHT
NOW ONE IS IT'S MORE RELATED TO
THE CONGESTION AND THAT'S THAT
CONTAINER ACCESS TO WELL HE-
THAT WAS ADOPTED AND PROPOSED AS
A DETERRENT. TO ENCOURAGE- THAT
THE CONTAINERS THAT WORD
SPENDING EXCESS TIME INTHE
TERMINALS. YOUR COURAGE THOSE TO
BE PICKED UP AND MOVED OUT OF
THE TERMINALS IF THEY'RE THERE
FOR LONGER THAN TWO. DAYS- NINE
DAYS THEY'D BE SUBJECT YOU WOULD
BE AND AS A RESULT OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF FIFTY IT'S HAD
ITS INTENDED EFFECT AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO SEE. A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN LONG
TWELVE TRAINERS THAT HE HAS
BANNED THAT POSTPONED NUMEROUS
TIMES. MOST RECENTLY THE
ANNOUNCEMENT CAME OUT IT WILL BE
POSTPONED UNTIL AT LEAST
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH I BELIEVE IS
THE DATE. BUT IT'S BEING
RECONSIDERED AND AS LONG AS IT'S
CONTINUING TO HAVE THE INTENDED
EFFECT OF- OF. GETTING BETTER
THE LONG DWELL CONTAINERS MOVED
OUT OF THE TERMINALS. WILL
CONTINUE TED TO POSTPONE IT
BECAUSE IT IS NOT WORKING AS IT
AS INTENDED. THE OTHER RATE
THAT- YOU MENTIONED IT IS
FEARED- THAT CLEAN TRUCK FIND
RATE. THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH- PORT OF LONG BEACH IN
FRONT OF LOS ANGELES. YOUR
INITIATE ON APRIL FIRST AND
THAT'S A RATE THAT WE WOULD
CHARGE AGAINST TRUCKS THAT CALL
AT THE TERMINALS. IF THEY DON'T
MEET CERTAIN STANDARDS SO THEY
WOULD HAVE EXEMPTIONS IF THE
TRUCKS ARE ZERO EMISSIONS. OR
EXEMPTIONS IF THEY'RE LOW KNOCKS
UNDER AT A CERTAIN SPECIFIED SET
OF IT EXEMPTION CRITERIA THAT.
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT ON THE LOW
KNOCKS TRUCKS ETWEEN THE TWO
PORTS. THE RATE THAT WE WOULD BE
CHARGING IS TEN DOLLARS PER
LOADED TDO AND ON AVERAGE. WITH
THE MANAGER RT OF TRUCKS BEING
AT- TO TEACH YOU WOULD BE
CHARGING ON OUT ABOUT. DOLLARS A
BOX. THAT THAT WE GENERATE WITH
THE RAPPER FROM THROUGH THE RATE
WILL BE YEARS TO HELP AND- THE
TRAIN. AND THAT. CLEANER AND
WHAT DOES YOUR IMAGE TRUCKS THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT TWO. SO THAT
WILL HELP US TO GENERATE FINDING
PAY FOR THAT TRANSITION INTO
HELP EXTRA. THE INTRODUCTION UP
THOSE THOSE CLEANER TRUCKS INTO
THIS WEEK BUT IT ALSO. IS ONLY A
PART OF WHAT WE NEED WE TALKED
ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE WITH
THE COST FOR THESE TRUCKS SAID
TOGETHER WITH THAT FINDING THAT
THE ANTICIPATED THROUGH THE
STATE. FINDS ME HERE- THIS THIS
ONE THAT WE'RE GENERATING WHAT
HELPED TO SUPPLEMENT. THOSE
OTHER EFFORTS AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND DO WE HAVE ANY REVENUE
PROJECT. FOR CLEAN TRUCK FUND
RATE. SO BASED THAT CARGO
VOLUMES THAT WE'VE SEEN AND THE
AMOUNT OF DRUG ACTIVITY AND THE
TRUCKS THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
PAYING THE RATE WE'RE
ANTICIPATING THAT THE FUND WILL
GENERATE BETWEEN EIGHTY AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
GUESS MY- FOLLOW UP TO THAT IS
THAT WE CONTINUE TO. PUSH NOT
ONLY- OURSELVES HERE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE BUT REALLY
PRIVATE INDUSTRY AS WELL TO BE A
PART OF THIS PROBLEM AND SALUTE
OUR PREP PART OF THE SOLUTION
EXCUSE ME. TO BE ABLE TO PIVOT
TO ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST- FINAL FINAL QUESTION
IS FOR ANY OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND WE TALKED ABOUT- OF COURSE
LABOR ISSUES. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BUT IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE WHAT MORE CAN THE
LEGISLATURE DO AT THIS POINT I
KNOW THAT THERE'S- IT'S STILL A
LITTLE MURKY IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE COST TO COST DIFFERENTIALS
ARE FOR CHARGING HEAVY DUTIES
AND FOR THE ACTUAL TRUCKS
THEMSELVES. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE TRUCK DRIVERS THAT ARE
IN AND AROUND THE PORTS- BUT
ANYTHING- SORT OF LAST COMMENTS
FROM STAKEHOLDERS- THAT. WOULD
BE HELPFUL. I DID. NOBODY ELSE
IS GONNA JUMP AND I WILL AGAIN.
YEAH YOU KNOW I THINK I THINK
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT
WE SHOULD NOT UNDERESTIMATE THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE CHANGE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IMPLEMENTING THERE ARE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AHEAD OF US TO BE
ABLE TO GET THERE AND TO DO IT
SUCCESSFULLY. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE CONDUCT
THESE DEMONSTRATIONS THE LARGER
SCALE DEMONSTRATIONS THAT. WILL
BE COMING ONLINE HERE IN THE
NEAR TERM WILL BE REALLY
CRITICAL TO HELP US ADVANCE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES. WE SHOULD
NOT UNDERESTIMATE THE CHALLENGES
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
GOING TO BE NECESSARY. TO BUILD
OUT TO SUPPORT ME. JEEZ PLANNING
IS A CRITICAL PART OF THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE.
HOW DID THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
TO BE. PROVIDED IN A WAY TO
SUPPORT THOSE OPERATIONS SO THAT
THAT IT WILL WORK FOR OUR
OPERATIONAL NEEDS. AND WE ALSO
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY
THAT YOU'RE- STARTING WITH
CARROTS AND ALSO EATING FOR THE
STICKS WE NEED TO HAVE CLEAR
TARGETS OF WHERE WE'RE GOING. SO
THAT WE CAN FOCUS OUR ATTENTION
AND REALLY WORK OUR WAY THROUGH
THESE REALLY DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES. AND THAT AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALL
WORKING. TOGETHER TO DO THAT
WHERE SUBSIDIES SO THAT WE DON'T
LEAVE ANYBODY BEHIND. AND IN
THIS TRANSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY- AT YES PLEASE
GARDNERIAN THE TITLE AGAIN. I
THINK IN THE- SPIRIT- AS- HOW
MANY I MENTION WE SHOULD UNDER.
ARE A BILL TO BE AND THEN. AND
BE ABLE TO BE SOLVERS AT THE
PROPRIETY YOU KNOW OVER TO YEARS
AGO CAN A ROBOT MARS WE HAVE
BEEN A ROBOT MARTIN GET BIGGER
OUT ENGINEERING AND TECHNOLOGY
ALL OF THAT. IT'S MORE ABOUT THE
WILL- POLICYMAKERS AND PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER AND BEING REALLY
INNOVATIVE I MEAN IS OF THE ACT
AND- WE DO NOT RECALL THAT YOU
HAVE GENERATIONS OF PEOPLE THAT
WILL HAVE- YOUR PREMATURE DEATH
AND ARE REALLY MINIMAL HOW. AND
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS REAL WE
SEE IT EVERYDAY ON THE GROUND
AND IT'S REALLY ABOUT TAKING
ACTION AND CELEBRATING. HELLO
THANK YOU. I COULD ALL JUST BILL
UP FROM I'M ANGELES SAYING- YOU
KNOW IT WE HAVE ALL THOSE. FOR
THIS IS A- YOU KNOW WHAT IT
TAKES TO TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION WE KNOW WHAT IT TAKES.
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS WHAT WE NEED IS THAT
WILL AND DESIRE TO GET IT DONE
AND IN SOME CASES FUNDING
INITIALLY. TO HELP GET US OVER
THE HUMP IN THE NEAR TERM. BUT I
WOULD ALSO URGE YOU ALL TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO STRUCTURE
INCENTIVES TO LEVERAGE PRIVATE
DOLLARS PARTICULARLY ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE. I THINK TOO
OFTEN WE'RE FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW
WHAT THE REGULATORS WITH THE
UTILITIES TO NEW- BUT IN REALITY
YOU KNOW THIS TRANSITION ALSO.
PAID THE MANUFACTURERS OF THESE
VEHICLES AND WE'RE SEEING THEM
AGAIN TO STEP UP AND DO THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE DAIMLER BLACKROCK
AND NEXTERA ENERGY JUST MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT. THE OTHER WEEK
ABOUT A HALF A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN. LONG HAUL
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO IT'S THOSE
KIND OF THINGS THAT YOU NEED TO
BE- DOING. THANK WOULD NOTE.
THAT THERE ARE TO STRUCTURE
INSIDE TO. YEAH J. SAID POLICIES
AS WELL PARTICULARLY ON LIKE THE
LABOR SIDE OF THINGS SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE ATTACHING A GOOD
LABOR PRACTICES AND STANDARDS TO
ANY INCENTIVE DOLLARS THEY WERE
GONNA BE GIVEN TO FLEETS OR
MANUFACTURERS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
IDENTIFYING TARGETED COMMUNITIES
STATE. THESE VEHICLES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. INCENTIVE DOLLARS
TOWARDS THOSE WHO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK-
MYSTERON WILL HAVE A FINAL BUT
WE DO HAVE A LAST QUESTION BY
SENATOR RUBIO. YOU THINK YOU
KNOW JUST TO EXPAND A BIT ON ONE
OF THE LAST POINT THAT THE-
RAINS- IN TERMS OF FUNDING YOU
KNOW I MENTIONED THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE. FULL
IMPLEMENTATION AND PROGRESS
REPORTS ONE OF EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE CARP HAD THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMPANIES THAT ARE RECEIVING
FUNDS THROUGH KERR- ARE IN FOR
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH OUR STATE
EMPLOYMENT AND TAX LAWS AND THAT
THEY STAND COMPLEMENT. CLIENT
YOUR THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF THAT
SUBSIDY- AND ALSO AGAIN YOUR FOR
CHRISTMAS SB THREE THREE EIGHT
WHICH- YOU KNOW YOU WORK SO HARD
TO MAKE SURE. WE GOT THAT-
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE TO EXPAND
CRITERION TO CREATE- RETAILER
JOINT LIABILITY YOU KNOW I THINK
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT. I
HAVEN'T HEARD BE DOES MENTION
THAT STEVE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE CARGO OWNERS REALLY ARE THE
ONES. THAT ARE PROFITING OFF OF
THE SYSTEM AND THAT HAVE THE
POWER TO- NOT JUST ENSURE THAT
THERE. ARE HIGHLY RISKY INTEREST
IN THEIR AND THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS
BUT ALSO BEHIND HIM ARMED STATE.
I'M IN A FAMILY OF IT AGREED
WITH MR SHIMON AND THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT TRUCKING
COMPANIES THAT ARE GETTING OUR
PRECIOUS PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE-
CAPITAL IT'S ENOUGH AND SOLID
ENOUGH TO- MAINTAIN THE VEHICLES
TO MAKE SURE THE TRUCKS ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
ALSO RESPECTING THEIR DRIVERS
LABOR RIGHTS AS WELL. AND SO
THAT YOU KNOW AS AGAIN-
DISTRICT. CENTRE FUNDS THAT WERE
MAKING SURE. THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST POSSIBLE STANDARDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR AND SO.
RUBIO HAS A QUESTION. VEXED WITH
A LITTLE BIT A COMMON THINK I
WANT TO THINK PART A LOT OF LONG
BEACH FOR A JUST COMMITMENT UP
TO A ALL CLEAN TECHNOLOGY. AND I
KNOW THAT LONG BEACH I KNOW THE
AREA WELL IT IT'S VERY CLOSE TO
MY DISTRICT AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S WHERE NATURALLY PEOPLE GO
IN TERMS OF BY. CARGO IN TRUCKS
AND WE DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
ABOUT IT IN THESE INNER CITIES
RIDE SO I WAS THINKING IN TERMS
OF REGIONAL SUPPORT WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO
HELP CREATE THIS WITH THESE-
REGIONAL NETWORKS WHERE EVERYONE
HAS. CHARGING STATIONS REFUELING
STATIONS NOT ONE COMMUNITY GETS
STUCK I HAVE IN THESE TRUCKS
COME THROUGH THERE AND THERE ARE
AREAS HOW CAN WE SUPPORT THAT
REGIONAL. A PLAN REGIONAL
APPROACH- JUST TO MAKE IT
EQUITABLE ACROSS THOSE REGIONS
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY CANNOT OR
NOT THEY'RE NOT LONG BEACH BUT
YET WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
THE TRUCKS COMING THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY. ARE YOU REFERRING TO
LIKE IN IN LEARN INLAND PORT
MODEL WELL YOU KNOW I'M THINKING
MORE ABOUT THE YOU KNOW WHEN WE
THINK OF LIKE CHARGING STATIONS
REFUELING STATIONS RIGHT WE
THINK OF LONG BEACH IN TERMS OF
THAT'S WHERE THE CARGO IS ENOUGH
FOR THE FREIGHTS ARE BUT- BUT
THE TO COME TO OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AND I'M JUST THINKING.
REGIONALLY EARLIER I HEARD YOU
SAY THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE LIKE
YOUR TARGETS FOR THE FUTURE YOU
TALK ABOUT THE UNCERTAINTY A LOT
OF A KNOWN SO WE WHEN I HEAR
THESE THINGS I ALWAYS. THINK DO
WE NEED TO REALLY. AND ALLOW FOR
THE OF A- UP WHERE THESE CHARGE
STATIONS ARE GONNA WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT FIND. AND PUT FIGHTING AND
IN THE AREAS. MAKING SURE THESE
AGAIN THESE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE ALSO ACCESS TO PLANNING AND
BEING ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS I
GUESS I. WANT TO SEE HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT. A MUCH BROADER PLANNING
. REPORTS TO SUPPORT- YOUR YOUR
EFFORTS- CERTAINLY AND I THINK
THAT MISS TIMELY IF YOU'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THAT JUST ON. HOW
WELL SEEN OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE OUR
ADJACENT PORT COMMUNITIES BUT
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY INLAND THE
INLAND EMPIRE THAT SEES THESE-
AFFECTS OF- YOU KNOW EMISSIONS
AS WELL SO IF YOU'D IKE TO
ADDRESS THAT ON. ON WHAT ELSE.
IS BEING DONE MORE ON IN IN SORT
OF A REGIONAL APPROACH. TO
SENATOR RUBIO'S QUESTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT FOR THE
QUESTION AND FOR THE-
RECOGNITION OF. THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND IMPORT OF
LONG BEACH. WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ALSO JUST
RECENTLY COMPLETED A CHARGING
AND FUELING STUDY SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND. THE
CHALLENGES WITH BUILDING OUT
THAT THE CHARGING AND FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO WHERE
THERE MIGHT BE OPPORTUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT WITHIN
THE BOUNDARIES OF THE PORT. WE
ALSO JUST RELEASED A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. FROM THE- CHARGING
I AM. YEARLING SUPPLIERS. TO
GIVE US PROPOSALS LOOKING AT
YOUR PARTICULAR SPOT IN THAT
PORT OF LONG BEACH WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BUILD OUT-
CHARGING STATIONS. TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR MISSION TRACKS BUT
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS IT'S NOT JUST
CHARGING AND FUELING IN THE
COURT ITSELF WE NEED A REGIONAL
NETWORK LIKE YOU POINTED OUT.
YEAH WELL TO SUPPORT THESE
OPERATIONS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
AREA THIS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATIONS OF GOVERNMENT IS
WORKING ON AN INFRASTRUCTURE
STUDY THAT THEY'RE JUST KICKING
OFF NOW AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING ON OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS I HEARD
COMMISSIONER MORNING HAND TALK
ABOUT HOW- CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IS ALSO WORKING ON A
STATE WIDE STUDY. I THINK THAT
THAT THOSE STUDIES ARE GOING TO
BE CRITICAL FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE. BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND FROM THE LIMITED WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE AND HELPING TO
PUT AN INFRASTRUCTURE WE BUILT
TO PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS IN
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH. AND
WE'VE ALSO BEEN TALKING WITH
SEVERAL OTHERS ABOUT BUILDING
OUT ADDITIONAL ONES THERE ARE A
LOT OF CHALLENGES WITH PUTTING
IN THESE CHARGERS A LOT OF
CHALLENGES WORKING IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS WITH NAVIGATING
THROUGH THE PERMITTING PROCESS
TO PUT IN HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS AND PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
CHARGERS. AND SO FROM THE STATE
PERSPECTIVES. HELPING YOU
ASSEMBLY TATE HE IS AN AND
MOVING THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO
THAT WE CAN MORE EASILY
CONSTRUCT AND INSTALL THESE
TYPES. OF INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THIS THESE REGIONAL
TRUCKS IN AREAS WHERE THEY DON'T
IMPACT THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WITH ADDITIONAL TRUCK TRAFFIC.
IT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL FOR US
TO DO THE PLANNING THAT CAN READ
NEED TO BE AND THEN TO HELP
FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION SO
THAT THEY INFRASTRUCTURE CAN
COME ONLINE AS. QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE YOUR SUPPORT YET THIS
YEAR AND OFFER. ON THE TIME
LINES THAT WE'VE WAITED. THANK
YOU MISS THING YOU SENATOR RUBIO
AND- I AM LAST YEAR WE ACTUALLY
PASSED THROUGH THIS BODY SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE A BILL THAT I
AUTHORED CLEAN PRINT CORRIDORS
IT LOOKS AT FIVE. WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IT
LOOKS AT FIVE MOST CONGESTED
HIGHWAYS- BUT THE NOT JUST THE
FREIGHT CORRIDORS BUT ALSO
SEGMENTS OF THE QUARTERS THAT
WOULD SPEAK TO YOUR QUESTION ON
LIKE IN A MORE OF A REGIONAL%
APPROACH TO LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN. DEPLOY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AND- AND VEHICLES
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SENATOR RUBIO I SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ON PANEL NUMBER TWO
PANELISTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME. AND YOUR
PRESENTATIONS WE MOST APPRECIATE
THAT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
FINALIZE OUR PRESENTATIONS HERE
WITH PANEL NUMBER THREE BY
INDUSTRY. OF THE FIRST PANELIST
WE HAVE AS MS NICOLE RICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION.
WELCOME MISS RICE. WELCOME THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME MADAM CHAIR YES WE CAN. OKAY
PERFECT- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF ONCE AGAIN
NICOLE RICE AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION.
C. NG C. REALLY APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DISCUSSION
TODAY WE FEEL THAT IT IS
EXTREMELY TIMELY AT THIS
PARTICULAR JUNCTURE IN THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TRANSITION JUST
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT TODAY. THAT'S A LONGER
TERM STRATEGY SEEMS SET BUT WHAT
WE DO IN THE NEAR TERM. AND
THERE'S BEFORE I GO INTO MY
PREPARED AB WHOSE INFORMATION
NETWORK COUPLE THINGS THAT I
WANTED TO ADDRESS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT. THIS IS NOT A CHOICE
BETWEEN ZERO AND NEAR ZERO. THIS
IS ABOUT DIESEL VERSUS CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES AND WHEN THE TIME
OF THOSE TURNS WITH EASE OF ALL
. THE ALTERNATIVE TO THROUGH
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS HEALTH
TRUST ISN'T ELECTRIC. IT'S
DIESEL AND SO IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE FINDING ABOUT HER
DEATH LIKE RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
POWER PLANT DAY THEN BASICALLY
THE STATE IS WALKING IN THE
CHOICE OF MEANS ALL WORK LEAD
OVER. OWNERS FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
TECHNOLOGY FOR A NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES AND TRUCKS IS ALREADY
AFTER IT'S SENT IT'S BEEN FUNDED
BY THE PRIVATE INVESTMENT BY THE
COMMUNITY. AND THEY CAN ALSO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION TO
HYDROGEN. SO IF ANY OF THE TIME
LINES OR CAPABILITIES CAPACITIES
OR ABILITIES THAT WE HAVE
FORECASTED FOR THE FUTURE ARE
WRONG OR OFF. AND THEN WE WILL
JUST LOSE MORE TIME AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE THINK THAT IT'S
CRITICAL FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WHAT THEY WILL DO IN
THE NEAR TERM AS WELL AS A LONG
TERM STRATEGY. SO FOR THE
CONCLUSION OF MY COMMENTS ALL
WRAPPED THEM AROUND A COUPLE OF
THINGS. FIRST OF ALL WHAT ARE
THE BENEFITS OF NATURAL GAS
STRUTS ALSO KNOWN AS LOW NOT
STRUCK NEAR ZERO TRACK. AND
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT
DISCUSSION TODAY SO I'LL JUST
WRAP IT UP BY SIMPLY SAYING.
UNTIL HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS ARE TRULY COMMERCIAL
VIABLE THAT MEANS THAT THEY CAN
OPERATE AS A ONE TO ONE REPLACE.
THE EXISTING AND DIVERSE DIESEL
FLEET THEN RENEWABLY YOUR WERE
NOT TRUST ARE THE BEST EFFECTIVE
AND IMMEDIATE SOLUTION TO
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S AIR QUALITY
AND CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. IN THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR. AND WE WERE
GLAD TO HEAR. THAT YOU'RE
RANDOLPH BELIEVES THAT THERE IS
A ROLE FOR ALL TECHNOLOGY TO
CONTINUE IN THIS TRANSITION AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH KERR. TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. HOW CAN THIS TECHNOLOGY
HELP THE LEGISLATURE MEET AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
WELL HERE'S AN EXCITING POINT
THAT WE JUST RECENTLY LEARNED
FROM DATA THAT WAS RELEASED BY
CAR. RELATED TO THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD THAT CERTIFIES
THAT NATURAL GAS USED IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS CARBON
NEGATIVE NOW. SO WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT CALIFORNIA ON NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES ARE ONLY CARBON
NEGATIVE TRANSPORTATION FUEL
OPTIONS THAT. CALIFORNIA WANTS
TO GO CARBON NEUTRAL NOW BEEN
ORANGEY IS THE FEW OPTIONS. AND
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT WELL FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE REQUIRES THE STATE
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM SHORT
REQUIREMENTS WRITTEN AND SIGNED
TO SEVEN BURKE TODAY HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THE BEST
SOLUTION. IS ONE OF THE CONSUMER
WARMING UP THE PLANET IS A RAPID
REDUCTION OF SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS LIKE METHANE AND
BLACK CARBON. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE LIVING WITH UNHEALTHY AIR
MANY AND DISADVANTAGED AND
MINORITY COMMUNITIES SO GETTING
IMMEDIATE NEAR TERM RELIEF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IS IMPORTANT. SIMPLY
ALLOWING DIESEL TO BE THE
DEFAULT IN THE ABSENCE OF
COMMERCIAL READY EVIDENCE
MISSIONS FACT WHEN CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE NOW IS
INCONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES AND ITS
DESIRE FOR A HEALTHY STATE AND
HEALTHY CALHOUN. SO I'LL CLOSE
BY SAYING AGAIN THAT THE CURRENT
CHOICE THAT WE OPERATORS ARE
MAKING TODAY IS NOT BETWEEN YOU
HEARING MISSION AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF LOW KNOCKS AND
GETS. ITS BETWEEN DIESEL AND A
CLEANER AVAILABLE AND RELIABLE
ALTERNATE. IT I CAN'T STRESS
ENOUGH THAT REPORTING MORE LOW
KNOCKS TRACK IT'S NOT GOING TO
SLOW DOWN THE ADOPTION OF A ZERO
A ZERO EMISSION STRATEGY THAT IS
THE STATE'S LONG TERM STRATEGY
WHAT WE NEED NOW IS A NEAR TERM
STRATEGY. AND ABSENT AN
ALTERNATIVE WHICH WILL CONTINUE
TO BUY DIESEL AND THE PROBLEMS
THAT THE POLICIES WERE TO
ADDRESS. AND SAW WHAT WE GET
WORKS. ONCE THE STATE WAITING
FOR THE NEXT BEST TECHNOLOGY MS
RICE IF WHATEVER HAPPENS- I'M
SORRY WE'VE GONE PAST THE THREE
MINUTES THANK YOU SO MUCH
ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY JUST A
FEW JUST A LASSEN. EVERY YEAR
THAT THE SWEETS TURN OVERTRACKS
THE STATE SHOULD BE PROMOTING
THE CURRENT BEST TECHNOLOGY. AND
TODAY THAT TECHNOLOGY IS LOWER
KNOCKS TRACKS. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND APPRECIATE
THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS DISCUSSION THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH MISS RICE WE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION. OUR
NEXT WE HAVE OUR SECOND PANELIST
IS THERESA COOK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION WELCOME MISS
COOK. SENATOR GOOD AFTERNOON AT
THE PLEASURE TO BE WITH ALL OF
YOU TODAY THREE FOR COOKING I
CAN'T DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION AND- I GET MY
SCREEN READY HERE FOR MY FREE
POWER POINT NOT COMING THROUGH.
IT LOOKS LIKE YEAH WONDERFUL ALL
RIGHT SO JUMPING AND WILL KICK
THINGS OFF WITH FUEL CELL VERY
ATTRACTIVE. THIS SEGMENT OF
HEAVY DUTY IS IN THE PRE
COMMERCIALIZATION PHASE I'VE
MENTIONED EARLIER THE STRUCTURE
CAPABLE OF CARRYING A FULLY
LOADED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
POUNDS OF GOOD. MILEAGE VARIES
ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED
TO FIVE HUNDRED MILES AND THE
TORQUE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
PLATFORM ALLOWS FOR BETTER
MERGING AND PASSING ON HIGHWAYS
REAL VALUE ADD WHEN WE CONSIDER
HOW TERRIBLY EVERYBODY'S DRIVING
THESE DAYS. THE REAL VALUE
PROPOSITION FOR FEELS ALL
TRACTORS IN THE HIGH RATE OF
UTILIZATION REFUELING TAKES
ANYWHERE BETWEEN FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY MINUTES ALLOWING THESE
TRUCKS TO BE UTILIZED 95% OF THE
TIME. VEHICLE COSTS ARE NOT
WIDELY AVAILABLE AT THAT POINT
MARKET DEVELOPMENT AS NOTED WERE
IN A PRE COMMERCIAL FAITH THAT%
ALL OF WILLIAM'S ARE STRIVING
FOR COST. CHARITY THE TEETH ALL
OPERATIONAL COSTS THEY CAN BE UP
250% OF THE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP AND TO THAT END WE
WOULD RECOMMEND YOU AREA TO
FOCUS ON. FIRST DECREASING THE
COST OF HYDROGEN FUEL CURRENTLY
ANYWHERE BETWEEN TWELVE TO
SIXTEEN DOLLARS PER KILOGRAM
VERY EXCITED ABOUT- PRESIDENT BY
IN HYDROGEN BURKE SHOT TRYING TO
GET HYDROGEN Q. A DOLLAR PER
KILOGRAM BY TWENTY THIRTY. BUT
ALSO WE WANT TO DO MORE TO
ENCOURAGE IN STATE RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION TO BUILD OUT
OUR- SUPPLY OF FUEL BURNING DOWN
**** A QUICK MAN IN COMPONENT
COSTS ARE ALSO A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP. AND HERE IS WHERE WE
CONSIDER THE DYNAMICS BETWEEN
HEAVY DUTY AND LIGHT DUTY THE
CLASS EIGHT TRUCKS THAT IS
OPERATING OUT OF THE PORT OF LA
IN THE BOTTOM RIGHT HAND CORNER
IT'S ACTUALLY TWO PASSENGER
VEHICLE MIRAI FUEL CELL STACKS
PUT TOGETHER. AND SO WHEN WE
COMPARE TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
PASSENGER VEHICLE PERSON ABOUT A
MILLION AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
IN THE STATE WHAT WE FIND IS
THAT BY SCALING UP THE
PRODUCTION OF LIGHT DUTY THE
COLD WE CAN DRIVE DOWN THE
VEHICLE COSTS AT THE HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS. CONVERSELY THESE TRUCKS
HAVE A BIG DEMAND ON HIGH. FUEL
THAT I WE UP TO MEET THE PRICE
DROP FOR EVERY DRIVING ON THE-
VEHICLE. AND EVERYBODY AGREE
THAT IN. IN THE FIELD ELECTRIC
COMMUNITY MUST PRECEDE VEHICLES
. THEY'RE THE KIND OF CATCH
TWENTY TWO THAT EXIST FOR
HYDROGEN WE'LL TALK ABOUT
FUNDING LATER BUT THE PCS
ALLOCATING MORE THAN 70% OF ITS
DOLLARS TO BATTERY TRACKS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE PURCHASE
ORDERS. GETTING LARGE VOLUMES OF
FUEL CELL OUR PURCHASE ORDER
ORDERS REQUIRES AN ABSOLUTE
ASSURANCE THAT A FUELING NETWORK
WILL BE AVAILABLE WHICH WE CAN'T
DO UNTIL WE HAVE MORE PURCHASE
ORDERS TO SELL IT FACT TRAP THAT
HYDROGEN ALL. GET STUCK IN AND
TO BE QUITE FRANK IT'S VERY- ON
ARE REMINISCENT OF WHAT THE
LIGHT DUTY MARKET IS GOING
THROUGH. SO WE'LL CHAT MORE A
LITTLE BIT. A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT OFFICIALLY. SEVENTY THREE-
O. G. YOU'RE HIDING MOBILE AND
HAVE DONE SO MUCH TO PROVE THE
VALUE PROP. IF YOU'LL FOLLOW
ELECTRIC. REPUBLICAN THEN AN
OPERATION SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
BEFORE COURSE THEY'D HAVE AN
OPERATING CONDITION PUTTING THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MILEAGE IN ONE
YEAR AT A FUEL CELL VEHICLE DOES
IN A LIFETIME BECAUSE THEY'RE
OPERATING 99% OF THE TIME.
FORKLIFT DRIVER GET PAID BY THE
NEW SO FOR A TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND UTILIZED 99% OF
THE TIME DEMAND IS HIGH THE SAME
COULD BE SAID FOR MATERIAL
HANDLING AND PORT. LOOKING TO
TRANSIT ANOTHER FUEL CELL
WORKFORCE CALIFORNIA HAS CLOCKED
MORE THAN SIX MILLION PEOPLE
ABOUT SMILE TO DATE. THE NUMBERS
HERE DO NOT INCLUDE BUT- BUT
THERE'S THAT TRANSIT DISTRICT-
ARE GOING TO BE ORDERING AS PART
OF THEIR INNOVATIVE CLEAN
TRANSIT. COMPLIANCE NUMBER TWO
INCREASE AND I COMING YEARS.
WE'LL TELL YOU TODAY BOX ARE.
AND DOLLAR EACH. AT NEW PEOPLE
ONE OF THE- WE- ACTIVITY. IT'S
GETTING A OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR AN ORDER OF A
HUNDRED ADDED SOMETHING SO AGAIN
WE RUN INTO THE ISSUE OF TRYING
TO SCALE UP PRODUCTION TO DRIVE
DOWN COSTS. THE LINE TRANSIT OUT
OF COACHELLA VALLEY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRANSIT OUR NATIONAL
LEADERS IN THE STATE. OF MIND
AND HAD A ZERO EMISSION POLICY
IN PLACE THANK YOU NINETY FOUR.
OPERATE TWENTY ONE PUPIL BUT
TODAY I'M WAITING TO TAKE
DELIVERY ON FIVE MORE THEY ARE
SHOWCASING THE PERFORMANCE OF
FUEL CELLS IN EXTREME HEAT JUST
LIKE OHIO'S. STARK AREA REGIONAL
TRANSIT AUTHORITY IS DOING WITH
EXTREME COLD. ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSIT AUTHORITY HOW THIRTY
NINE FEEL FOCUSED ON THE ROAD
AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING TO FIVE FIVE FIVE
STUDIES THAT THIS IS A COPY AND
PASTE YOU SEE IN THE BOTTOM
RIGHT HAND CORNER. WHICH IS AN
ANALYSIS COMPARING ALL THE
AVAILABLE DRIVE TRAINS IN TURN
IN TERMS OF COST PERFORMANCE AND
RANGE. FOR THIS COMMUNITY
HYDROGEN FUEL COSTS- PRIORITY SO
AS WE DISCUSSED WITH DRAYAGE
TRUCKS THE HYDROGEN OR CHAU IN
INCREASING STATE PRODUCTION
CRITICAL OBJECTIVES FOR THIS
COMMUNITY THANK YOU MISS COOK IF
WE CAN JUST WRAP UP HERE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT WE'RE PASSED THE
THREE WORDS WE APPRECIATED. NOT
A PROBLEM I AM I THINK THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH DISCUSSION ABOUT
NOTHING THAT FEDERAL WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND GET IT SO I WOULD JUST
ADD INCLUDING THAT ADDING
TOGETHER ALL STATE SPENDING ON
YOUR MACHINE VEHICLES. LESS THAN
5% OF THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE
GOING TOWARD HYDROGEN DESPITE
THE VALUE THAT IT BRINGS TO
HEAVY DUTY AND AT THE AARP
RECOMMENDS 20% OF PASSENGER
VEHICLE. I'M SO THE COMMITTEE
ASKED WHAT WOULD OUR SUGGESTION
B. Q. ELIMINATE BURIAL TO
COMMERCIALIZATION AND SO MY
ANSWER TO THAT WOULD BE WE NEED
TO STOP LIMITING HYDROGEN INTO A
SMALL AFTERTHOUGHT. ONLY BE USED
WHEN WE'VE EXHAUSTED ALL OUR
TIME AND RESOURCES FORCING
BATTERY. CREATING. POLICIES THAT
ALLOW HYDROGEN JUST SCALE CREATE
ALL. AND BE WITH NOW THREE OUT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR. THREE
TECHNOLOGIES BECOME TO COME. AND
STAND ON THE OWN I DON'T BE WHY
THEY- TO ALL HELLO. RIGHT THANK
YOU BETTER YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRO. WE THAT AND WE YOU CAN
PROVIDE THAT- THE PRESENTATION
DECK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL THIS IS- GREAT TO HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS- OUR NEXT AND FINAL
PANELIST IS MS I LEAN WINGER
TAPPED EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION. THANK
YOU MISTYPED A WELCOME YOU MAY
START. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SALAS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE HERE TODAY
AND MORE ARE COMING AND I AM
GOING TO SHARE MY SCREEN HERE
I'M HOPING YOU CAN ALL SEE IT.
LOOKS. CAN YOU SEE THE ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY INFANTRY YES
WE CAN'T. SO THEY'RE HUGE
ELECTRIC TRUCKS ARE HERE TODAY
ON MOST PLATFORMS AND FROM A
VERY DIVERSE RANGE OF
MANUFACTURERS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS TOOL THAT CAL
START CREATED ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY INFANTRY ZEDI WHERE
YOU CAN SELECT A REGION AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT THESE TRUCKS. ARE
AVAILABLE ALL OVER THE WORLD
THIS IS NOT JUST CALIFORNIA THAT
SHIFTING SHIFTING TO ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS THE WHOLE WORLD
IS GOING THIS DIRECTION SO WE
ARE WE ARE FAST FOLLOWERS BUT
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES WE'RE
NOT THAT WE'RE NOT THE LEADERS.
SO YOU CAN SELECT A REGION WITH
THIS TOOL SAY THE U. S. AND
CANADA AND YOU CAN SELECT A
PARTICULAR KIND OF TROPICAL WILL
SELECT A CARGO VAN HERE AND YOU
CAN SEE WHICH MANUFACTURES MAKE
THIS TRUCK IN YOUR REGION. AND
THEN YOU CAN SCROLL DOWN AND GO
TO SUBMIT YOUR INFORMATION AND
SUBMITTING CALLOUSED ARE AND
THEY WILL HELP- THE CUSTOMER
FIND THE TRUCK THAT YOU WANT SO
THAT IS JUST TO SAY THAT NOT
ONLY ARE THE TRUCKS HERE BUT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING SO FAST
THAT THERE'S A TOOL AVAILABLE TO
HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN TRUCK DRIVERS AND FLEETS THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. FIND THE RIGHT TRUCK
FOR THEMSELVES I'M NOT GONNA
PRETEND LIKE WE'RE NOT IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF
COMMERCIALIZATION BECAUSE WE ARE
BUT SENATOR DOLLY SAID EARLIER
YOU WERE ONLY FOURTEEN YEARS
AWAY AND I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
THAT FOURTEEN YEARS IS A VERY
VERY LONG TIME AND IN THIS IN
THIS WORLD AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHERE WE WERE FOURTEEN
YEARS AGO ON ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION WHICH WAS PRETTY
MUCH KNOW WHERE. AND WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. IS PRETTY. THE
AMAZING SO I JUST WANT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT KNEW THAT THERE WAS
TOOL THERE AND THEN I ALSO
PROVIDE HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE IT A
HANDOUT. FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES.
PEOPLE POINT TO THE GRID AS A
CHALLENGE TO ELECTRIFICATION.
AND I JUST WANT TO. SHE SAID
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STUDIES AND SOME OF THEM ARE
LAID OUT IN YOUR HAND OUT. THAT
SHOW THAT LEAKING THESE TRUCKS
TO THE GRAND CAN BE A TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT FOR THE GREG. FOR SAFETY
FOR A LIABILITY AS WE WORK ON
RESILIENCY AND COMBATING
WILDFIRES THESE TRUCKS
CONNECTING TO THE GRID CAN MAKE
OUR GRID MORE RESILIENT
PARTICULARLY AS- THE FLEET TURNS
OVER RATHER SLOWLY SO THERE IS
THIS KIND OF GRADUAL TURNOVER IN
THE FLEET. AND THIS IS NOT A NEW
CHALLENGE FOR UTILITIES- THE
UTILITY INDUSTRY THE GRID ITSELF
IS AN ENGINEERING. FEAT THAT IS
EVER OF ALL- AND SO THIS KIND OF
NEW LOAD IS NOT NEW FOR THE
GRANT WE HAVE. IT THAT THESE
KINDS OF CHALLENGES ARE NOT NEW
IN FACT THEY CAN OFTEN BE.
BENEFICIAL TO THE GREAT AND ALL
CUSTOMERS WHO USE ELECTRICITY
WHETHER OR NOT YOU DRIVE A
TRUCK. SO FOR JUST TO GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE OVER THE LAST DECADE.
MARGARET IN CALIFORNIA HAS
SHIFTED SUBSTANTIALLY TO A
RELIANCE ON RENEWABLE RESOURCES
SOLAR AND WIND HEADED HAVE
EXPANDED. ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
THE STATE HAVE X. HAS EXPANDED
SO THIS TRANSITION CAN NOT ONLY
BE ON BE. BENEFIT THE GREAT BUT
IT IS POSSIBLE IN PART BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
GRADUAL TRANSITION AND IT ISN'T
A NEW THIS IS NOT NEW TO WORK
FOR THE GREAT. SO I DON'T WANT
TO UNDERESTIMATE THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO NOT JUST
TO BRING ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
CONNECT THEM. TO THE GRANT BUT
ACTUALLY ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO
ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
COMBAT WILDFIRES WHILE ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT ELECTRICITY IN
CALIFORNIA IS MORE AFFORDABLE
AND SAFE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
SO I GUESS I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING WHEN YOU HEAR THINGS
LIKE- YOU KNOW THE GREAT CAN'T
HANDLE THIS OR THERE ARE ALL
THESE GREAT CHALLENGES. I WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO USE
PLEASE TALK TO UTILITIES TO THE
EXPERTS TO THE ENGINEERS WHO WHO
KNOWS THE FACTS SO YES WE DO WE
ARE FACING A LOT OF CHALLENGES
IN CALIFORNIA. THEY ARE LARGELY
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE BUT I
WOULD POSIT THAT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES CONNECTING TO THE GRID
ARE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND-
I'M NOT THE HYDROGEN PERSON BUT
I THINK HYDROGEN IS ALSO
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ON THEIR
TREMENDOUS- THAT. STORAGE
CAPACITY SESSION WITH HYDROGEN
SO THESE VEHICLES ACTUALLY CAN
SUPPORT OUR GREAT EFFORTS AND
THEY'RE COMING ONLINE FASTER
THAN ANYONE EXPECTED WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND DATA ENHANCEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN BEFORE SO
WE HAVE CHALLENGES. THAT THERE'S
A LOT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DO
NOT. AND ACTUALLY YOU BACK TO A
LOT VERY VERY AGGRESSIVELY IN
SUPPORTING THIS TRANSITION SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU GONZALEZ FOR
INVITING ME I HOPE THAT YOU FIND
A HANDOUT USEFUL AND CONSIDER US
A RESOURCE. FOR TO ANY QUESTIONS
OR FURTHER INTERACTIONS WITH THE
SCRIPT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR WE
APPRECIATE. YOU BEING HERE IN
YOUR TIME AS WELL. EIGHT THAT-
CONTROL OUR PANEL. AND BEFORE I
GO TO MY QUESTIONS I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE PRESENTERS ALL OF
THREE PANELS THAT SPOKE FROM
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES- NOW TIME
WE WANTED AFTER WE TAKE A
QUESTIONS FROM THE SENATORS I'D
LIKE TO ENSURE THAT WE ALSO- A
LOT TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
SUGGEST. L. ONE OTHER REMINDER
TO PARTICIPATE PLEASE CALL THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER ONE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. THAT ACCESS CODE IS. NINE FOUR ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE.
I WE WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU BUT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE AND AGAIN WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
SENATOR QUESTIONS I HAVE SENATOR
ARE TO LET A FIRST. THANK YOU AN
OBSCURE I'D LIKE TO- COMMENT AND
THANK- ARE VERY LAST. A
PRESENTER IT BECAUSE SHE BROUGHT
BACK. MY INITIAL STATEMENT WAS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
TREASURE CHEST OF ENERGY AS WE
OPEN THAT TREASURE CHEST WE HAVE
TO INCLUDE EVERYTHING AND I
THINK THAT WAS. THE GIST
WEATHERED BE ELECTRIC FUEL CELL
ENERGY WHATEVER IT IS NATURAL
GAS IT ALL HAS TO BE PART. OF
OUR TREASURE CHEST OF ENERGY TO
GO FORWARD WITH OUR GOAL ZERO
EMISSION. BUT I'D LIKE TO GO
BACK TO OUR PANELISTS MISS COOK.
IN REFERENCE TO. THE HYDROGEN.
IT SEEMS THAT THE HYDROGEN. TO
BE THE ANSWER FOR NUMBER OF
HEAVY DUTY AND OFF ROAD
APPLICATIONS HAVING SAID THAT-
HOW CAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOW COULD THE INDUSTRY WORKED TO
BRING THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
PRICES DOWN- TO A REGIONAL ABOUT
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT MARKET-
NUMBER OF THAT GREAT MARKET
NUMBER WOULD KICK RULING THINGS
OFF. AT SIX DOLLARS A KILOGRAM.
YES THAT WOULD. ANOTHER GREAT
QUESTION SENATOR- SO I FULLY
AGREE THAT WE CAN GET SPEND MUCH
TIME ON THE WAY VISUAL OF ALL
THE NEW PRODUCTION COMING INTO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
VERY VERY EXCITING. FOR A LONG
TIME I THINK WE'VE BEEN KINDA
HIT WITH- YOU KNOW FRUSTRATION
ABOUT RELIANCE ON OUT OF STATE-
ISSUED SO THAT A LOT AND YOU
KNOW CREATING AND- STATE WHERE.
THESE SORTS OF ALTERNATIVE FUELS
ARE MOST WELCOME AND Q. AND YOU
KNOW USE THAT OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE HYDROGEN HUB. USE THE GOOD
WORK AT THE SCENE CARE BE DOING
AND GO BAD ARGUING TO CREATE NEW
PRODUCTION SITES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO THAT WE HAVE PRODUCTION
IN LINE TO SUPPORT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF HYDROGEN
APPLICATION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LIKE RAIL AND MARINE
AVIATION AND A OT. OF STUFF. I
HAVEN'T YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
NEED ABOUT THE IDEA. INVESTMENT
TAX CREDIT- BEING SORT OF A SHOT
IN THE ARM SHOULD THAT
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE WANT TO PRIORITIZE
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN PRODUCTION.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT MORE COSTLY
BUT IF THEY'RE YOU KNOW LIKE A
KEY. ISSUE FOR OUR INDUSTRY- YOU
KNOW TO BRING TO MARKET SO YOU
KNOW THAT TO BE A COUPLE OPTIONS. THAT OFFER FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
TO GET INTO YOU TO CAN. TO ALL
THE PANEL THEY'LL A GREAT JOB
AND AT THE YOU FOR TIME AND ONCE
AGAIN TO YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING THIS ALL
TOGETHER. I THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SEVEN OR NEWMAN. THANK
THANK YOU MEASURE GOD COULD VERY
QUICK QUESTION FOR MISS COOK- IF
YOU COULD PLEASE EXPAND BRIEFLY
ON YOU DOWN THE POINT YOU KNOW
IT WHICH IS THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP OF THE
INTERDEPENDENCY. BETWEEN THE
LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY DUTY BUT
WHILE ALSO- SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
TOWARD THE PROCESS OF GREENING
HYDROGEN- AS WE GET TO SCALE. ON
THIS PLATFORM. ABSOLUTELY AND I
DID LOOK THROUGH THAT PRETTY
QUICKLY IT'S GOOD TO HAVE PLAYED
DOWN AND FADE AGAIN. STILL IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE GOT ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES ARE GOING AROUND AND
WE'VE GOT ABOUT A MILLION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS. AND WHAT WE FOUND
FROM THE AUTO MANUFACTURER
PERSPECTIVE. INSIDES INVESTING
IN THE FACILITIES THERE- I.
PROJECT. THAT DEVELOPED. HE WILL
TELL FOR A LADY MARIAH AT A OLD
WHEN PRODUCED A LOT OF. FOR A
LOT LADIES VEHICLE FAILED. BACK
IN ASK DRAWS DOWN THE CAR OF
COMPONENTS IN THE COMPONENT IN
THE HEAVY DUTY FREE MAKING NOT
EQUIPMENT LESS COSTLY WHICH
BRINGS DOWN THE OVERALL PRICE AT
KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO HELP PRODUCT-
THIRTY KILOGRAM- FUEL TANK ON
BOARD BURST IS A FIVE KILOGRAM
TANK ON A LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE SO
WHEN WE CONSIDERED THE DEMAND
FOR HYDROGEN FUEL THAT GOING TO
COMPROMISE THE HEAVY DUTY
MARKET. NEEDING TO REFILL A
THIRTY KILOGRAM TANK THAT'S
GOING TO CREATE A DEMAND ON
HYDROGEN FUEL THAT ENCOURAGES
PRODUCTION AND THEN NOT DRIVE
DOWN COSTS. FOR HYDROGEN IT'S
ALWAYS ABOUT SCALING WHETHER
YOU'RE SCALING BE A QUICK
MENTION WHETHER YOU'RE SCALING
THE PRODUCTION OF FUEL THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION DOC WHEN YOU
START TO UNLOCK. COST BENEFIT
AND THEN WE MOVED TO A PLACE OF
BEING EVENTUALLY SELF SUFFICIENT
AND NOT NEEDING. TO BE
CONTINUALLY UPSET I'D- I AND
THEN YOUR QUESTION ABOUT.
ACTIVELY THE GREY. VERY GOOD
DISCUSSION WHERE I I'M ARE BOARD
CHER ONE I'M IN THE FIRST HAND
ALL ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
RENEWABLE PRODUCTION PATHWAY SO
YOU HAVE THE ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN ELECTROLYTES HERS AT
THAT POINT IN THE MARKET ARE NOT
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE THEY ARE
IN THEIR VERY EARLY STAGES- I
SORT OF DEMONSTRATION AND
DEVELOPMENT SO I WOULD NOT IN
THAT MOMENT POINTED THAT OUT AS
THE PRIMARY MEANS TO MAKE YOU'LL
CONCRETE IMMEDIATELY ARE COST
COMPETITIVE IMMEDIATELY. BUT YOU
HAVE TO EITHER HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION PATHWAYS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD WHICH
IS THE PROGRAM THAT WE KIND OF
YOU KNOW THAT OURSELVES
ACCORDING TO WITH OUR NORTH
STARKEY WELL I'M AND HAVE BOTH
OF THOSE PRODUCTION PATHWAYS
RELY ON ORGANIC WASTE
AGRICULTURAL WASTE- YOU KNOW
LANDFILLS AND MUNICIPAL WASTE
THOSE STREAMS. ARE YOU KNOW AND
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER LEFT
UNTOUCHED ARE JUST GOING TO
RESULT IN GREATER AND GREATER
METHANE EMISSIONS BUT AS
CALIFORNIA'S OWN SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANT BILL AND THEN
I DIDN'T ADMINISTRATION AND
ACTION PLAN FOR METHANE
REDUCTION THOSE TWO PRODUCTION
PATHWAYS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO PRESERVE AND SO THE
POINT THAT I WAS HOPING TO MAKE
EARLIER IS SOMETIMES THERE'S A
LOT OF PUSHBACK ON HYDROGEN
BECAUSE CURRENTLY WE RELY ON YOU
KNOW CREDIT FOR OUT OF STATE.
BUT I THINK THAT THE TEMPORARY
ISSUE AND THE THING THAT'S GOING
TO RESOLVE BACK IN HAVING OUR
OWN IN STATE PRODUCTION BUILT
OUR OWN STATE RENEWABLE
PRODUCTION BUILT OUT AND THEN
WE'RE NO LONGER YOU KNOW
INSERTED THAT PUSH AND PULL AND
WE CAN STAND BY YOU KNOW OUR OUR
IN STATE VERY CLEAR READY WILL
ALL PRODUCE HYDROGEN. AND FORMER
HAD. ENTER YOUR- THAT DOES A DE
AS SELF CHAIR THE HARSH AND
CAUCUS I THINK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN US OPEN CHAIR
LEFT- I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE QUESTIONS DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER MIKES BUT I DO HAVE A FEW
TO BILL OFF THE- LAST ONE
RELATED TO HYDROGEN I MEAN WE
TALKED A LOT YOU. YOU BUT A LOT
OF- EXAMPLES THANK YOU MISS
COOK. BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WE DIG
DEEPER WE SEE THERE ARE OTHER.
ELEMENTS THAT BECAUSE- I GUESS
SOME QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF
STORAGE ISSUES TRANSPORT ISSUES
ENERGY EFFICIENCY ISSUES. AND SO
I'D LIKE TO TALK THROUGH THAT A%
LITTLE BIT JUST TO GET. A SORT
OF AGLOBAL PICTURE OF WHAT- THE
STATUS OF HYDROGEN IS CURRENTLY
IN AND WHY IT'S- I GUESS SO FAR
BEHIND IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW IF
WE ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT.
OTHER- TECHNOLOGIES. AND HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN WILL CONTINUE TO
WEIGH IN I MEAN OBVIOUSLY WERE
WEIGHING IN NOW BUT HOW LONG CAN
WE- LOOK AT HYDROGEN IN THE
DIFFERENT LANDS RELATED TO THOSE
ISSUES. BUT A GREAT QUESTION-
AND SO. I WANT TO POINT TO
SOMETHING THAT I NEED TYPED THAT
WHICH WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COMMENT MADE BY SENATOR DOLLY
ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS BEING A
LONG WAY AWAY. AND YOU KNOW
HYDROGEN AND THE YOUNGEST OF OUR
FAMILY HERE- AND SO YOU KNOW WE
ARE AS I MENTIONED AND NOT PRE
COMMERCIAL PHAE- SO I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME. TO PROVE OUT THE
APPLICATION OF THE VEHICLES AND
THEN ONCE WE START TO FEED. MY
BAND HARM FOR DEATH TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS THAT'S WHEN PRIVATE
INVESTMENT START TO COME TO
MARKET. AND BE YOU KNOW COSTS
COME DOWN DISTRIBUTION ISSUES
INVESTED AND- YOU KNOW I TAKE
YOUR POINT WELL DIED IN THE
MARKET RIGHT NOW. AND WE DO HAVE
A PRODUCTION PROBLEM WE HAVE
THAT WE HAVE AN AVAILABILITY OF
FUEL PROBLEM IN OUT OF SOMETHING
THAT I'M COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN
MENTIONED IN HER TESTIMONY AND-
THAT IS ALSO WHY I'M SO EXCITED.
ABOUT THE INCREASED PRODUCTION
THAT COMING TO CALIFORNIA.
EHRLICH HE'D WILL BE OPENING AT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PRODUCTION FACILITY. THAT
IS- PRETTY THING THIRTY
KILOGRAMS OF- EXCUSE ME THIRTY
TONS OF RENEWABLE HYDROGEN PER
DAY. THAT WOULD SUPPORT FORTY
TWO THOUSAND LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
OR ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES OR- YOU KNOW ABOUT
SIXTY THOUSAND FOR CLASS AND
THAT'S NOT BE ONLY. THIRTY TIME
PER DAY PROJECT THAT COMING TO
THE WEST COAST WE DON'T HAVE A
PROJECT UNDER DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW AND SO. I GUESS I WOULD ASK
SENATOR FOR JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
PATIENCE I NEED- YOU KNOW KIND
OF. GET THROUGH OUR AWKWARD
TEENAGE YEARS IF YOU WILL SO
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO COMPETE IN
THE MARKET. I'M AND THEN OTHER
RELIEF TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY YOU
KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE.
HEAR AN AWFUL LOT THAT. YOU
KNOW- HYDROGEN THEN YOU KNOW I
FOR AND IT NOT THE HIGH IN USE
THAT AT THAT- I THINK WE'RE
MEANT THE- OF THE POINT IS WHAT
ARE CAN HUMOR. GOING TEN NEEDED
WHAT ARE TRUCK DRIVERS GOING TO
NEED WATER THE PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE AS AS AS
AUTOMAKERS. HAVE BEEN DELIVERED
CANNOT. AND INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW
KIND OF GETTING CAUGHT UP IN THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY ARGUMENT I
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO
STAY FOCUSED ON WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW TWENTY NINE MILLION DRIVERS
AND YOU NEED TO GET THEM
VEHICLES THAT CAN MEET ALL OF
THEIR DEMANDS- WITH MINIMAL
SACRIFICES HYDROGEN AND THE ONE
TO ONE REPLACEMENT. FOR GASOLINE
AND I THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER- MISS
COOK- AND THEN MY NEXT QUESTION
IS FOR- IS RIGHTS RELATED TO-
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AS WELL. I THINK IN
IN ONE OF YOUR- FLYERS HERE IT
HAD MENTIONED WHAT COULD BE
ACHIEVED WITH A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. AND
IT IT DEPICTS OF THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES FUNDED OF VERSES. FOUR
TIMES MORE THAN BATTERY ELECTRIC
SO TO WHO. I GUESS YOUR SCENARIO
HERE IS TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS- TRUCKS. VERSUS SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRUCKS. AND SO. WHAT IS THE COST
DIFFERENTIAL I KNOW AGAIN THAT'S
BEEN A QUESTION WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THROUGH THESE
PANELS BUT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE IN THIS IS JUST ON THE
VEHICLES OF COURSE NOT. YOU KNOW
RETROFITTING OR A CHANGING OF
ANY OTHER- FUELING STATIONS BUT
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE GIVE US
A PICTURE- OF WHAT- THIS
ACTUALLY MEANS. THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIR SO IF YOU'RE ASKING THE
COST DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN. THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES IN THE
DIFFERENT VEHICLES. SO FOR- A
DIESEL LIKE I USED TO DIESEL
VEHICLE YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT-
SIXTY TO EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A TRUCK- AND YOU CAN WE ARE VERY
COMPARABLE TO THAT FOR NATURAL
GAS IT DOESN'T USE VEHICLES IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A NEW. AND
IS ON TRACK THAT'S NEED BE-
CLOSE TO LIKE MAYBE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND- AND WE ARE
VERY COMPARABLE TO THAT. BUT
ONCE YOU'RE GETTING TO YOU OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES I'M YOU'RE LOOKING
AT TWO TO THREE TIMES THE
AMOUNT. OF THAT CLASS WITH THOSE
TRACKS AND THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY AS WELL THAT YOU
TO THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT- AND
THEN AND THEN WHEN YOU GET TO
USE THE HYDROGEN SHOTS. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SIGNIFICANT. COST
INCREASES WELL. OKAY THANK YOU
THAT- MAR FORMULA THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING IS WHAT IS THE HERE
IN THIS- THAT THIS FIRE BECAUSE
YOU ALSO- INCLUDE THAT THE KNOX
REDUCTION ANNUALLY COULD BE- ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE
TONNES WHICH IS FIVE TIMES MORE
THAN BATTERY ELECTRIC. IS THAT
CORRECT. I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR I
WAS PULLING UP NOT TALKING IT'S
LIKE IT'S- NOT JUST GIVE ME A
SECOND LET ME PULL THAT. IS NOT
ON MY SCREEN. OKAY AND CAN YOU
ASK THE QUESTION AGAIN I'M HERE
YES THANK YOU I THINK THAT-
LEAFLET IS- TITLED CALIFORNIA
HAS THE WORST AIR POLLUTION IN
THE NATION AND DIESEL TRUCKS ARE
LARGELY TO BLAME. AND THERE ARE
ON THE BOTTOM LEFT IS FIVE TIMES
MORE THAN BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRUCKS THE BASED ON THE SCENARIO
OF. TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO A NATURAL GAS TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD VERSUS SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRUCKS I GUESS YOU'RE COMING UP
WITH THE SCENARIO THAT YOU WOULD
REDUCE. KNOCKS ANNUALLY ABOUT.
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN BATTERY
ELECTRIC TRUCKS. THAT THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY AND THEN GHG
REDUCED ANNUALLY WOULD BE ABOUT
FOUR TIMES MORE- THAN BATTERY
ELECTRIC AS WELL. THAT IS
CORRECT AND THAT'S ALL BASED ON
A ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. CORRECT WE WERE TO
DO THAT NOW OKAY DO YOU SEE AN
ANY ADDITIONAL I KNOW LAST YEAR-
WE HAD WORKED ON- A FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT THAT
WAS ENACTED THROUGH- OUR BUDGET
ACTION. AND SO. THIS YEAR I IT
LOOKS LIKE I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IS IN
ADDITIONAL. BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
IS. FROM WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
THE PUBLIC IS. IN WHAT I'VE
ASKED BEFORE IS WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL- INAPPROPRIATE INVESTMENT
FOR THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND I
THINK I OFTENTIMES ARE LOOKED AT
AS QUOTE UNQUOTE BRIDGE
TECHNOLOGIES. AGAIN WITH THE
SEVEN TO TEN YEAR STRATEGY
HORIZON WHILE WE'RE ALSO
SIMULTANEOUSLY LOOKING AT
IMPROVING THE INNOVATIONS FOR
ZERO EMISSION. IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AS WELL AND WHAT
OTHER. DOLLARS WOULD YOU BE-
ADVOCATING FOR FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. YES WELL- SO WE
FIRST OF ALL AND NURTURE WE
WOULDN'T CHARACTERIZE THIS AS A
BRIDGE TECHNOLOGY WE THINK THAT
THIS IS A TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
AVAILABLE AS I SAID IN MY
TESTIMONY TO HELP THE STATE MEET
BOTH AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS. SERVICE TECHNOLOGY
IS AVAILABLE TO CONTINUE TO RUN-
YOU KNOW IT S. AS LONG AS IT IS
NEEDED AND PROVIDING THOSE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS INSTANCE ON
THE IN THE DOCUMENT. CARE ACT
YOU KNOW NINETY PLUS PERCENT
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN CHIEF FOR
OR NOT NO 100% AND EMISSIONS FOR
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER SO- SO
WE DON'T CHARACTERIZE IT AS
THAT- HOWEVER. FOR THE
INVESTMENT INVESTMENT DOLLARS IN
THE INCENTIVES- THAT SUPPORT OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS NOW
ONLY THROUGH ONE PROGRAM WHICH
IS THE CALL MORE YOUR PROGRAM.
AND WE WERE IN A VARIETY OF
OTHER PROGRAMS- OVER THE YEARS
THAT HAVE. SUBSEQUENTLY BEEN AND
JUST PROVIDED RESOURCES FOR
INCENTIVE CREDITS AND DOLLARS
THRILLED THE CARMELITA PROGRAM
BUT THAT'S REALLY TO HELP WITH
THE COST DIFFERENTIAL FOR THE
VEHICLES THAT WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT AND REALLY GOES TO
SUPPORT. THESE SMALL FLEET
OWNERS THOSE WHO HAVE YOU KNOW
TWO OR FIVE OR TEN TRACKS WHERE
I'M TURNING THOSE TRUCKS OVER
ISSUE A CLEANER TECHNOLOGY MIGHT
BE PERSONALLY DESIRABLE BUT A
LOT OF TIMES IT'S NOT FEASIBLE
ECONOMICALLY. SO WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE STATE CONTINUES
TO TAKE ON FRANKLY AT TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL APPROACH Q.
INCENTIVIZING. THE USE OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES CONSIDER BOTH NEAR
TERM AND LONG TERM STRATEGY AND
AS FAR AS DOLLAR AMOUNTS AS YOU
MENTIONED THE FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS PROVIDED AS A
BUDGET ALLOCATION LAST YEAR.
ACCORDING TO YOU AND THE
DISTRICT A SOUTH. COAST AT&T-
EARLIER TODAY. WHERE DOES THE
ARE WITH THE SOUND OFF VALLEY.
AMERICAN SOLUTION CONTROLLED.
WOULD ALSO FROM THOSE WE- THAT
COULD- DISPLAYS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TRUCKS IN THE
DESPERATE SO IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT AS MUCH
RESOURCES AS WOULD BE NEEDED FOR
A THOUSAND TRAFFIC THE
DISPLACED. BUT IT STARTS MAKING
PROGRESS AND FOR THE REASONS
THAT THE STATE WITH THEIR
FEDERAL AT THE TEAM MADE MANDATE
IS IMPORTANT- SO THAT GOES TO
SHOW THAT JUST FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS HOW SIGNIFICANT
THAT IMPACT COULD BE. SO BEING
ABLE TO YOU ALLOCATE RESOURCES
ACCORDING TO YOU AIR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS FOR
THE NEAR TERM AND THE LONG TERM
IS THE BEST WAY THAT THE STATE
COULD PRIORITIZE HOW THOSE
INVESTMENTS GO. AND AGAIN TO
SUPPORT HELP ME- SMALL LEADS AS
WELL AS LARGER FLEET OWNERS
START MAKING THE CHOICES FOR
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY THAT WE KNOW
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE. BUT
MIGHT BE HAVING FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTY AND- CONSOLE. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER APRIL THAT AND
I THINK MY HURTS A CALL. A
FOLLOW UP FROM OUR A RESOURCE
BOARD IT'S JUST GONNA COME THANK
YOU. SURE THANK YOU SIR I AM
CARDS DEPUTY FOR MOBILE SOURCES
AND INCENTIVES THAT'S ONE OF
REFLECT IN A FEW OF THE THINGS
YOU'VE HEARD. THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL THING TO SAY IS
THERE ABOUT A MILLION TRUCKS IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT IS NOT FUNDS TO
REPLACE ALL THOSE TRUCKS HAVE TO
SPEND LIMITED STATE FUNDS. AND
THEN THE ANSWER IS REALLY CLEAR
COMBUSTION WHETHER NATURAL GAS
OR DIESEL IS NOT THE RIGHT
ANSWER THE BOX THAT. THE STATE
HAS INVESTED OVER BILLION
DOLLARS ALREADY I'M IN
COMMERCIALIZING NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES THAT'S A SUCCESS.
THEY'RE AVAILABLE TODAY IN OUR
DISTRICTS ROUTINE DISCRETION TO
FUND THEM SO NO ONE'S QUESTION
WHETHER THE MONEY'S OUT THERE. I
THINK ONE REASON WHY THE CHAIR
SO HEAVILY EMPHASIZE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IS THAT WE
THINK ABOUT HOW TO INVEST
LIMITED FUNDS AS THE L. A. O. IS
OBSERVED. WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IF YOU SEE ONE OF
THOSE IS HOW IS EQUITY SO HOW
DEEPLY CAN WE INVEST IN TRUCKS
THAT WILL STAY ON THE ROAD FOR
YEARS TO COME IMPACTING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THAT
REALLY MEANS GETTING ZEROS WE
HEARD MISTER LOGAN. ANOTHER IS
THE TIMING INVOLVED WHICH IS TO
SAY AS BOTH A REGULATORY
PROGRAMS RAMP UP AND AS
MANUFACTURERS INVEST MORE ANY
VIS MATCH OF OUR STRATEGY IS
ENSURING THAT WE ARE. INVESTING
ONE FUNDS WE HAVE ACCELERATING
THAT TRANSITION. ALL OF WHICH IS
TO SAY. AND FINALLY I WOULD JUST
. FUELS ARE HERE. AND THERE'S A
LIMITED QUANTITY OF RENEWABLE.
GAS AND THEY'LL BE REAL QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER GOES INTO INDUSTRY
ORANGE TRANSPORTATION THE
FUTURE. TO RECONSIDER WHERE
WE'RE GOING HERE I JUST WANNA
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
PERSPECTIVE. THAT'S ONE REASON
MY CARB IS EXCITED ABOUT HIS
BUDGET PROPOSALS. AND GIVEN THAT
THEY HELP BUILD ON EXISTING
SUCCESSES NO ONE'S TAKING. ON
COMBUSTION VEHICLES OFF THE
TABLE. IN TERMS OF WHERE NEW
FUNDS ARE NEEDED I WILL SAY THIS
IS A MARKET WHERE WE REALLY CAN
SUPPORT. ON A GREAT MANY
ADVANCES IN ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY THANKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR US A CALL DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR MOBILE
SERVICES AND INCENTIVES WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- COMMENTARY
THERE- I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
MIKES UP. ON THE SENATE FLOOR-
IF THAT IS ALL THAT I WILL SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR
PANELISTS EMPANEL THREE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION AND
YOUR TIME- AND WE CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO. FOLLOWING UP WITH
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT AGAIN I'M GOING TO
REMIND THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE
TO CALL IN THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. ACCESS CODE
NINE FOUR ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE. WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU BUT PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE EACH. WILL BEGIN FIRST
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. C. NINE WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK
EACH. A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AGAIN TO REMAIN WITHIN A ONE
MINUTE REMARKS MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT THIS MOMENT. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT VIA THE PHONE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN WHY
NOT BEEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE IN THE QUEUE.
GLOBAL TEL NINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND ARE HAPPY NINE MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS STATEWIDE. THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING ON THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. TOP
OF YOUR POWER AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES MEANT UNACCEPTABLE
AMOUNTS OF CO TWO BOX AND FINE
PARTICULATE POLLUTION
CONTRIBUTING TO CLIMATE CRISIS.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE'RE ADVOCATING AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD FOR THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE ADVANCE CLEAN
SHEETS ROLE AND FOR MEASURES IN
THE STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT WILL PHASE OUT POLLUTING
HEAVY. DUTY VEHICLE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. AMONG OTHER THINGS ARE
. IS A CAR KERR TO REQUIRE A
100% SALES OF NEW HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES I TWENTY THIRTY SIX.
USE THE SIDE THE FLEET'S COVERED
BY THE HC AFTER ALL. AND MANDATE
THE RETIREMENT OF POLLUTING
TRUCKS ONCE THEY REACH THEIR SB
ONE USEFUL LUGGAGE. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS CARBON OTHER
AGENCIES TO BE BOLD IN OUR HEAVY
DUTY TRANSPORTATION LAWMAKERS.
FOR AMERICA LEGISLATURE MUST
CONTINUE STRONG INVESTMENT IN
ZERO EMISSION HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RETRACT PROJECT HALF MEASURES
SUCH AS SO CALLED NEAR ZERO
TRACKS. BECAUSE IT'S CHAIR
RANDOLPH SAID DURING THAT
HEARING. THE FUTURE IS ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND TRACK WISHIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
YES NEXT TO THE BOTTOM TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM HERE NUMBER LEE
AT THE LOCAL ARM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE TEACHER CALIFORNIAN GOOD
MOVEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE IS TOP
OF MIND RIGHT NOW SO I
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
PUTTING ON THE PANEL TODAY AND
THE COMMENTS FROM ALL THE
PANELISTS. WE AGREE WITH
COMMISSION RUNNING HAND IN MANY
OF THE OTHERS MADE LARGEST
CHALLENGES ENSURING THAT THAT
MUST BE MADE DURING IN CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE NORDERNEY ARE
TWIN GOLDEN DIRECTING CLIMATE
CHANGE OF REDUCING AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS WHILE THE SAME TIME
INSURING WE WILL CONTINUE TO
EFFICIENTLY MOVE GOODS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION. I
CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THE
MONUMENTAL TASK THAT IS BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. ALL WHO
WORK TOGETHER TO COORDINATE
FAILED PURCHASE IS PROCESSED
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
INCENTIVES IT'S NOT A PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE CHARGING VIDAK CHARGING
TIME BRING DOWN COSTS. AND
ENSURE THE BASIC GREAT GREAT
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE AMOUNT
THAT EXPECTED TO COME ONTO THE
MARKET OKAY THE LEGISLATURE MUST
ALSO BE PREPARED TO CONTINUE TO
DEDICATE A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
THE BUDGET BUDGET FOR YEARS TO
COME IN ORDER TO ENSURE RELIABLE
OPERABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
DURING. YOUR COULD GOTTEN. THE
STATE BUDGET AND THIRTY. THE
UPRIGHT COSTWILL FALLING CAL
BUSY IN. COULD SHOOT TO BE
EARLIER. TO TURN OVER THE FLEET
. I'LL BE CULTURE IN UP DATA
SHARE ANOTHER. SHARE ON CHARGING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL HAS.
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU.
MAKE COMMENT PLEASE. YES A DAY
HAVE A THREE IN THE KEY GLOBAL
TO LINE FIFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOOKING IN YOUR MEMBERS THE GUN
JOB OF THE READ THE NUMBER NOT
THURMOND THE COLD AND MORE
EIGHTY BUT THAT MAY OF WHOM DO
TIPS DASCHLE OPERATE WILL CAL.
THE MAJOR BENEFITS INVESTORS WE
WORK WITH RECOGNIZE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE POSES SIGNIFICANT RISKS
TO THEIR LONG TERM ECONOMIC.
ENTER IN THE LIVELIHOOD OF THE
COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY OPERATE
FOR THESE REASONS MANY HAVE HOPE
PUBLICLY SUPPORTED A STRONG
ADVANCE CLEAN TRUCK REGULATION
INCLUDING COMPANIES WITH MAJOR
FLEET. PATAKI AT NESTLE AND
CONTINUE TO ADD FOR TARGETS FOR.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FOR.
TRANSITION IN YOUR MISSION
TRUCKS. COMPANY NEAR MISSION%
TRUCK TO THE COFFEE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND HAVE CALLED FOR
SUPPORT OF QUALITY TECHNOLOGY TO
PRODUCTION AND DEPLOYMENT OF
ELECTRIC TRUCKS AND CHARGING.
YOU THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ALL THE WORK TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
IN THIS SECTOR AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO GAIN MOMENTUM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. ON THE INVASION
EVENTINCREIBLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. SOME OF
THE LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
INSURANCE. EVEN AFTER WITH THE
ETHNIC BY THE BUMPING UP THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
SIMPLE EACH RECEIVED PROBABLY
THE HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC TRUCKS ARE NECESSARY TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE AND AIR
POLLUTION GOAL BECAUSE THEY
OFFER LONG RANGE INCLUDES
BILLING SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL. FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY CYCLE. THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
VEHICLES THE CORE FEELING
INTEREST TO AND WHITE OUT OPTION
. THE DIRECTLY WE BELIEVE HEAVY
DUTY HYDROGEN STATION SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE HR PROGRAM WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING A LOT MAY.
INCREASE YOUR CAPACITY CREATION
. ANOTHER CALL FOR LIKE YOU YOU
CAN BE REPLICATED IN THE HEAVY
DUTY THE- HUNDRED AND BY NOTING
THAT HYDROGEN IS A CLEAN FUEL
THE COUNT THE BELOW. ZERO CARBON
INTENSITY FOR AND THIS AND BEACH
BP ENCOURAGES YOU TO USE A
CARBON INTENSITY COURT I WOULD
USE IN THE HEALTHCARE SECTOR
GRAHAM TO DETERMINE YOUR
ELIGIBILITY AND HE CARBONIZATION
POTENTIAL. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COME PLEASE. MAXIMO TO LINE
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GONZALEZ MEMBERS THIS
IS SAM MONSON WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS- I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM SEVERAL POINTS
MADE STATEMENTS FROM THE
PANELISTS- KIDDING BY
REITERATING THE POINT IN
ACCORDANCE EARLY SIGNIFICANT AND
CONSISTENT ACTIONS TO ACCELERATE
OUR TRANSITION OF THE HEAVY
DUTY- SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA ZERO
EMISSION. ELECTRIC TRUCKS ARE
AVAILABLE TODAY AND COST
COMPETITIVE WITH COMBUSTION
TRUCK SPECIALLY WHEN CONSIDERING
BELIEVE DELIVERY VEHICLES- IN
RECENT PART ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT
ELECTRIC TRUCKS WILL HAVE A MORE
FAVORABLE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP AND COMBUSTION TRUCKS
IN ALL SECTORS BY TWENTY THIRTY
THE GOVERNMENT ACTIONS AFTER
PROGRAMS LIKE THE UPCOMING
ADVANCED QUICKLY TOOL EXISTING
REGULATIONS LIKE OFF THE
ASSASSIN INCIDENTS LIKE A
TRAPPER KEEPER GETTING US TO
COST. THE PUSH TECHNOLOGY
MARKETS FORWARD- BATTERY PRICES
NO SIGNIFICANT BODY COSTS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
ANTICIPATED TO DECLINE BY UP
270% BY TWENTY THIRTY THE
GOVERNMENT ACTION IS KEY HERE TO
SPUR THE MARKET- SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING UPFRONT ACCEPTANCE AND
FURTHER TILTING COSTS THIRTY
TOWARDS ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
ACTION FOR CALIFORNIA TAKES A
DAY WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
COMPOUNDED BENEFITS DOWN THE
ROAD AND THE INTERNET CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS URGES LEGISLATORS
FORMED STRONG ETF FROM CARD INTO
YOUR SEATS LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND- IN. DISPROPORTIONATE AIR
POLLUTION. THANKS SO MUCH HAVE
BEEN ANSWERING. THANK VERY MUCH
NEXT CALL PLEASE. AND THIS THERE
IS NO AND I'LL TO MAKE. OKAY YOU
MUCH- I WANT TO JUST ACTUALLY
THINK ALL OF OUR- ALL OF OUR P.
WITH THREE PANELISTS WE'VE DONE
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF HOURS NOW
FANTASTIC QUESTIONS BY SENATORS.
SO HAVING HEARD ALL OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN MEMBERS- I
DON'T HAVE ANY OF IT ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. SO WITH THAT- WE WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE AGAIN WHO
PARTICIPATED THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS WE'D
LOVE TO HEAR THEM. IN WRITING OR
YOU CAN VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE THE
PARTICIPATION AND WE HAVE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS WELL THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.